oh it's working
i thought it just crashed on us you get
a special opening now because we have
camera problems
ladies and gentlemen governor andrew
cuomo recently announced that he thinks
we need to reopen the economy
we can't do it soon enough we also heard
from mayor lori lightfoot of chicago
that
bars and restaurants need to reopen i
wonder what caused the
sudden change of heart from their
previous positions that basically defied
the science
since the start of the coveted
restrictions there have been some people
who have been standing up saying it's
unconstitutional
and it's unreasonable early on many
health experts and scientists were
saying
how about we protect the vulnerable we
protect those with pre-existing
conditions and comorbidities
and we allow young healthy people to
work because the science wasn't out to
justify
destroying the economy well there was
one gem
that defied the lockdown in a variety of
ways but uh
joining us now we actually have the the
owner of that gym ian smith
thank you for having me but uh but you
are still following like social
distancing and masks and all that stuff
right
yeah we opened up with a 15 we opened up
with a 15 point safety protocol
um when we reopened we didn't do it to
be defiant we didn't do it to um to push
back again
against government we did it to provide
a solution where there was none
you know they said 14 days and seven
weeks in we were still being told to be
patient
and we were still being told that there
was no plan to reopen so my partner
frank and i put together our own plan
we social distance we have temperature
checks at the door
we have a entirely touchless system
coming in we had contact tracing we have
record of every single person who's been
in the facility when what time what
their temperature was
with a health questionnaire that filled
out so and so forth you guys took it
seriously
very but you were just open and for that
you were fined a ridiculous sum of money
and so the big story which was we'll
just we'll get into it as we after we do
the general intros is that uh
the government stole a hundred and
seventy three
thousand dollars out of your bank out
now i know some people are like it was a
fine
you know someone said if you can't
handle the fine don't do the crime
well you're still in court over this
like they they took it before there was
even a ruling
on what was going on and it was your
legal defense fund wasn't it it was
we we haven't charged our members since
the beginning so that was all donations
towards the legal defense fund so we'll
we'll that'll be that's the big story
we're covering we got a lot more going
on i mean
so uh it's it's you know it's really
interesting we have we're particularly
fortuitous in getting our guests because
there's always some big story happening
around the guests that we bring in i
don't know how it happens but
in tunisia six hunt over 600 arrests as
riots break out because they're defying
the lockdowns in the netherlands
over 100 i think 142 arrests in mass
riots
142 arrests is huge for riots
i mean you rarely see that i remember
doing occupy wall street they'd be like
wow 70 people arrested it's a mass
arrest event because they
have to bring in two buses now in the
netherlands 142
people arrested some officers were
injured a horse was injured somehow i
mean
it's getting it's getting out of hand
and it's weird now
that we're seeing some democrats come
out like oh they're going to change
their mind so we'll see how that
all plays out and then we've got some
other stories martin luther king jr day
so naturally there are some events
and we'll have some cultural commentary
on twerking for martin luther king jr
i'm down people want to celebrate
however they want that's fine so of
course
ian smith from adolescent is joining us
but we also have luke rodkowski writing
things down well
ian i'm very happy you're here feel free
to move the microphone a little bit
closer if you want and he's going to be
providing us
very important feedback on the radowski
gym
that we just established here on the
beanie compound
absolutely location so uh we got we got
that looking forward
to and uh welcome back beautiful and
amazing human beings my name is
lukadowski and i run the youtube channel
we are change and i'm here volunteering
my time
man it's so great when other ians are
here
confusing thank you for coming yeah dude
so kovid's in the food supply apparently
some chinese study they found it in ice
cream thousands of pints of ice cream
apparently they think it can live in
animal fat so
that is sending me on another twisting
uh wormhole
they can take our gems but they can't
take our ice cream i think this should
be front page
red alert news from the world health
organization that
covet can live in food wait this is a
chinese study though are we trusting
chinese
we trusted chinese no they told us there
wasn't any virus
before you know don't worry about it
they put doctors and journalists in jail
for telling everyone that there was uh
something going around that's logical
yeah
i'm being sarcastic but uh but no no ian
is is correct is it
ice cream it's interesting they don't
know much about it yet but they think an
employee
get or a group of employees put it into
the ice cream maybe
and then it's like dormant frozen it's
like it can live in
you see that episode of the simpsons
where homer buys the orange juicer
and then like in japan the guy coughs
into it and then they seal the box and
when he opens it the
japanese flu hits him in the face and
he's like ah he screams and
oh there's a whole thing that just
follows along the theme of the simpsons
just predicting everything
so seriously this is just another one
just chalk it right up when
when when covet first started a lot of
people were like another simpsons
prediction
it's like it's a funny bit where like uh
chief wiggum is running down the street
and he sees the cloud of germs chasing
him and just
shooting at it anyway anyway of course
star petulant is here she's pressing all
the buttons i'm here in the corner i'm a
member of the
rudowsky gym downstairs and uh i'm
excited for this evening
we're growing in membership i'm excited
yes i'm stoked to be great it's like
it's like
a treadmill and what is it a power cage
so it's called power cage
that's all you need yeah there's a bench
and uh
you know it's fun well let's uh let's
let's do this i'm gonna pull up this
news story but then i'm gonna throw it
to ian because you know well you're the
expert the story's about you
but what we have from fox news new
jersey gym co-owner
says state seized legal defense funds oh
i'm sorry i can't do this
i totally forgot we have a sponsor i was
like i'm going to read this news and i'm
like no
no no no no we have a sponsor we're
excited uh yeah i want to give a shout
out to to pocketnet
go to pocketnet.app and become a member
it is the first
fully decentralized social network and
that's actually
extremely impressive so in this in the
script in the description below you will
see a link to the site where you can
sign up they're sponsoring they shall be
eternally grateful for this
and i gotta admit um you know we talked
about it last week
ian and i kind of talked about it
because decentralization is the only
real solution
to the censorship problem because even
if you're
setting up your own infrastructure
there's always some chain link that can
be snipped out by some authoritarian
or enough enough pressure can get blocks
put on and there's even instances where
google sees the domain of some websites
just sees that outright using their
power to block people from being able to
go to certain websites
so with pocketnet you sign up
decentralized and they say this
what makes them different from all the
big platforms there is no central
authority or corporation
the platform is run by equal nodes on a
blockchain all revenue is split between
node operators and content creators
node operators stake pocketcoin in order
to mint blocks with rewards
and transaction fees half of rewards in
each block go to content creators
based on ratings their content gathers
from users
i'll be completely honest um we you know
we get a series of sponsors
and i'm not usually this excited about a
project
so it looks pretty good ian what do you
think i made an account on pocketneck i
really like it um
it's you'll notice it's slow i think
because when you make a post it writes
it to the blockchain and it'll say like
writing to the blockchain wow and then
they pay you i got a couple of pocket
coins from like interactions so the
crypto market is is thriving
um they said specifically that the app
that you get from google right now and
pocketnet.app website
are ultimately not it's they're good
they work but
they're still centralized google can
take it down so they said if you really
want the
unstoppable pocket net to go to their
github um they have a link
from their main account on pocketnet
when you sign up you can find their main
account and they'll link you to their
github
and then you get the desktop app which
cannot be censored it's a decentralized
app if there's at least a few people
hosting it around the world
it stays we've repeatedly talked about
this you know look when we do sponsor
spots we normally
don't go this in depth but we've talked
about it a lot on the show
that we need a social network system
that's powered and structured
totally decentralized and there have
been a lot of attempts at it over the
years so
check out pocketnet.app in the
description below and special thanks to
them for sponsoring the show
but also don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member help support the show
we're going to have more and more
members only content coming up soon and
if you want to get the exclusive
i am a gorilla t-shirt go to timcast.com
click shop
and you should find the i am a gorilla
shirt we've already sold over 600 of
them
and we're going to be releasing a
tinfoil hat edition
special edition we're only going to have
it up for like a day or two so
we'll announce that happens anyway let's
get back to the news and uh thanks to
the sponsors
so this is a story from fox news this is
where were we new jersey gym co-owner
says state seized legal defense funds
amid battle over coveted fines
quote we had no money in our bank
account ian smith tells tucker carlson
tonight
well i don't need to read this but i
will mention 173
613 dollars stolen by governor phil
murphy
and his cronies but ian's here so dude
what happened
so uh just a regular day you know
opening our gym frank
my partner checked the bank account and
um i believe it was thursday morning
and it was bone dry down to the very
last penny
was it was there was there literally
like nope like zero zero dollars
um ever they took everything um and
next to it it had a you know a
transaction
for new jersey state execution you know
so
for the total amount for everything that
was in the bank account
but like how did they know what to
request or did they just say
give us the cash i'm pretty sure they
just called santa santander bank and
said
you're going to empty this bank account
now and they said sure and then
did they tell you why they did it no
we've got no explanation from anybody
all right so let's so let's let's break
down the story real quick um from the
beginning
you guys were locked down like everybody
else and then one day
you opened back up and the governor was
like nah none of that so what happened
uh so about seven weeks into the
lockdown frank and i decided that we
were going to reopen
we were going to do so publicly not not
because
we wanted the attention but because we
wanted to present a plan to the public
where all small businesses could use the
same measures that we had
adapted to their own business we were
looking around i think like most people
had started to at that point and saying
a lot of this doesn't make sense you
know the fact that all of these small
businesses
are villainized and deemed as unsafe but
you can slap a mask on your face and
wipe your cart down and go have a frenzy
in walmart
just wasn't really making sense so we
said okay we're going to devise our own
safety plan we went above and beyond
we went so far as to get hydroxyl
generators
which convert humidity in the air to
oh molecules runs uh 33 000 cubic square
feet
per per minute circulating air i mean we
did everything we possibly could to the
point where if they told us we couldn't
open it would be absurd
um and then we opened and we were met
with the heavy hand of government on day
one
and that just continued to escalate to
the point where now
eight months into it we have over 80
criminal and municipal charges
we've had our business license stripped
we've had a health department shut down
we've had our locks physically changed
we've had our
doors boarded up we've been arrested uh
we're fined fifteen thousand four
hundred and ninety seven dollars and
seventy six cents per day for every day
that we're in operation
um which was originally
a fine for being open and then once gyms
were allowed to be opened
they the attorney general called us and
said you need to mandate masks
and we said no we're going to make them
optional because while working out it's
not really a
smart thing to have your face covered
and it even says in the executive order
in new jersey that opened sports that
you shouldn't wear it during intense
aerobic and anaerobic
that's that's the government's actual
recommendation that's the government's
recommendation in the
executive order that opened indoor
sports yeah they said it's dangerous to
wear but in the executive order that
opened gyms
they said cloth face coverings are
required which
is just like the government makes no
sense you know it's
it's not surprising at all so so i guess
what i wanted to get to starting from
the beginning is some some people have
already you know commented in the chat
that
that money that was taken wasn't stolen
it was a fine you owed the government
right
sure sure it was a an unconstitutional
and oppressive fine
the laws when it comes to finding
businesses
um i think the exact word they use is it
should be a punitive sting
um and finding a small business that has
only been open for less than two years
15 497.76 per day is not a punitive
sting it's a death blow
um even one day yeah exactly even one
day i mean
our our membership revenue is
not that barely covers a month of
memberships a month you know it just
it's it's so out of proportion
that um those fines are unconstitutional
so we've been fighting them ever since
we're in the appeals process
so yes we are fine absolutely you know
people are right when they say
you know you're being fined correct but
the the process is not concluded yet
so you're actually this is your legal
defense fund you were in court
in court it's active litigation in four
different matters and so before there
was any resolution
they drained your accounts yep so so
here's my question was this account
an existing account you had or was it
new and set up for legal defense
this was an existing business account
but the money comes almost entirely from
our gofundme account
which is where people donate either
locally
because we don't charge for we don't
charge members we haven't charged our
members since april 1st
um first of all we didn't we didn't
charge because we weren't allowed to be
open
so we said we're just open you know we
weren't we weren't in it for the money
we were in it to
to win a legal battle um but then after
they stripped our business license
obviously
we can't charge so we haven't charged
it's all donations and then it's t-shirt
sales
do you own the building we do not but
our landlord is very accommodating
ah very accommodating yeah i wondered
about that because there's other
businesses too who have
you know defied lockdown and things like
that in various areas and i wonder what
the landlords are probably thinking or
you know i wonder if the government's
gone to them but i want to get to the
most interesting uh aspect
outside of this so first i just want to
make sure we stress that was the legal
defense fund for paying your lawyers to
challenge the fines in the first place
and they went and they took your ability
to defend yourself
that's crazy but let me tell you you
know i think the craziest thing is and
you can elaborate on this
so i actually i used to live right by
your gym like maybe like i think only
like three and a half four miles away
and we
we cruised over a couple times and
talked to some of the locals you weren't
there i'm not sure you know what
happened but you know
you guys had like the 14th amendment
written and put up on the windows and
stuff
so uh we went there after it was
announced that your gym had been flooded
yeah and so we talked to some locals who
told us something really crazy
that someone stuffed paper towels into a
like a sewage line
a vent or something in the back causing
a backup and that's this is what someone
told me so tell me tell me if this is
true or not
someone there said that the previous day
just before the flooding happened
there were two squad cars blocking the
alleyway behind both the entrance and
the
both entrances to the alleyway so
there's like a single stretch that goes
behind this
complex and they said that two squad
cars were like blocking the road
and the cops said you can't come back
here go away next thing they knew
someone back there jammed it full of
paper towels and flooded the whole
building there was also a
barrow of belmar water truck back there
too really yes
so wait wait dude coincidentally
coincidentally and that was that was one
of
seven times it happened i think i think
when you guys were there it was actually
the first time yeah we've had seven
sabotages in total
all the same thing like jamming paper
towels or what the
the building is is pretty old so whoever
is doing it and and i
i i do not claim to know who but it's
definitely intentional we've had
multiple plumbing crews come out and say
this isn't i mean this isn't you know
somebody took a big dump and and
you know had too much toilet paper this
is this is a very intentional act
whoever's doing it
understands that we have a very old
system
and what they're doing is is
manipulating
just a crappy old plumbing system so it
takes somebody who knows what they're
doing so and
just to clarify did you witness a water
truck
and police cars blocking that area we
had pictures of it yeah
i didn't i didn't personally witness it
but i had pictures sent in around that
time that we reopened
we had so many eyes and ears on the
place just because people were so
invested in our story and invested in
what we were doing that
there were people sleeping out in the
parking lot um during the opening nights
there were people kind of surveilling
the place
sending us pictures videos the whole
night is it possible that the
the the good hearted police were
guarding the water truck trying to
save your business from the flooding i
mean the water truck came out to try and
make sure you know
oh no it's gonna flood we gotta save
this guy it's it's hard to imagine they
would be doing anything else but that
well
[Laughter]
i was going to ask you how's your
relationship with the police there
because wasn't there one
viral video of an officer refusing to
kind of
go through with the order so so how has
that been
can you explain to people what happened
and your relationship with them yeah
absolutely i mean we
we notified the police we were going to
open we notified the mayor everybody so
and and that was because we didn't we
don't want to blindside anybody we knew
a lot of people were going to show up
and we didn't want to
to put the talent in a difficult
position any more of a difficult
position than we were putting it in um
so that video was actually from day one
at right about 12 o'clock
they they walked up and that was the now
retired police chief or
captain captain excuse me retired now
yes retired
he was um apparently he was on his way
out and he was done with the bs anyway
um but yeah he came up and he said
you're all in violation of an executive
order and he took a nice long dramatic
pause and he said on that note everybody
have a nice day
yeah and it was funny because back then
we were like yes we won we did it we did
it and yeah
uh governor murphy saw that video and 15
minutes later
the attorney general gerber gual called
the camden county prosecutor
or excuse me the county county yeah
county head prosecutor who then called
the belmar police department and said if
you do not get in there and take action
we are going to furlough the entire
belmar police department for
60 days yes that was and so and so the
spineless bellmar cops came in so the
second lieutenant who is definitely
uh definitely a bootlicker he was he was
anxious to please father murphy
um and came up and handed us our first
of
80 summons wow wow first so uh before
he showed up and issued the summons did
he go to murphy's house to lick his feet
[Laughter]
out of all the out of all the belmar so
we have a great relationship with the
belmar pd
most of them before covet were members
of our gym oh cool you know belmar and
you're familiar with the area
you know it's it's a local blue-collar
kind of middle-class area so our gym is
full of these kind of people they're
full of cops firefighters
um you know active and veteran military
um and it's a shame because they were
put in a bad
very bad position most of them didn't
want to be there from
the start and then as it started to
escalate
they were forced to do things that they
didn't want to do i disagree well
correct me if i'm wrong weren't people
arrested uh
for just attending your gym as well one
person was
several people were cited though and fun
fact
all of those citations are the only
still existing coveted citations for any
protesting during that time wow
all other charges have been dropped
except any regarding a telescope what
are they going to charge for
or what do they get violation of a
governor's orders which is this
archaic statute from like 1890 something
you sure didn't
they didn't say decree this is why i say
i disagree
because i remember watching this video
where i'm not sure if it was you or
somebody was saying you look the cops
are doing their jobs
they're being forced to do this nah i i
think any one of those cops could have
been like nah
and then they and then it would have
been done they wouldn't have gotten rid
of the police they wouldn't have froze
the department
if every single officer said do it
furlough us and then when you start
getting phone calls and they call for
your head
you come knocking give us a raise
whatever i've seen it happen in numerous
protests
you're you're right you're right but the
cops didn't take it would take that one
person just
to say no and then it would take the
other people to get up on the dance
floor with them and
yeah fortunately that doesn't happen but
i agree with you 100
if we had uh you know we've had too many
good times uh this this this past
several decades have been good times all
around and you know what i think i see
in my opinion what's going on is these
cops many of them can see the suffering
that you that your your customers that
your business the local business are
going through
and they can see the suffering of the
middle-class blue-collar worker who
can't feed his kids anymore and
they think i don't want to be like them
i'm getting a paycheck
so i'll lick the boot of whoever takes
if i get my paycheck so then
you know the problem i see is and with
all due respect
when people say well they have no choice
they do it's a job
they could say i will not oppress my
community
for a paycheck and if if at once
one person two people if all of these
regular
regular guys who are in the department
just said you're not gonna get me to do
it because i go to that gym
they're gonna get mad at me i'm not
gonna be able to go out for beers with
anybody anymore then they'd be like
sorry governor we can't do it you have
to bring in cops from a different city
because these these guys won't do it
instead they just say sure whatever
and then they get the other problem is
there's no penalty for the cops who
violate the constitutional rights of
individuals
the first amendment doesn't doesn't have
caveats
it doesn't right you we have a right to
assemble for whatever reason
ian let's go assemble to uh play magic
the gathering okay there's no the
the the first amendment doesn't say
anything about why you can assemble just
that you're just the right
yeah all it takes is for those cops to
say i won't violate the constitutional
rights of these individuals
and then it would not happen more than
that the problem is i don't think a lot
of them are educated on that
i don't i don't think when they sign up
for the job these days and and that's
that that doesn't excuse them by any by
any means but i don't even think that's
stressed anymore
in the police academy i don't think you
know you know that you know what i think
i think you guys are too good of people
i think that's really it i think you're
you're respectful and nice to these guys
because you know
you don't want those cops to be out of
work you don't you want you want
everybody able to work feed their
families
and so you give them the respect they
don't return and so long as the
community isn't willing to like you know
what you need
you need like uh what what what did
jorge say what's the what's the slipper
called that the the mom
yeah he was talking about how like you
know what happens if you go against you
know
they they hit you with the little
slipper you need you need something like
uh like a grandma to be like young man
what are you doing and have them be like
listen
it's not okay what you're doing to these
people but so long as the community says
thank you officer we respect what you're
doing
they'll keep doing it if you guys said
you do this you're never welcome here
again they'd think twice
you're starting i think you're starting
to actually see that you're starting to
see the cops
now get a lot of pressure from the right
as frustration
tends to mount i think in the beginning
of this it was the
you know especially the right tends to
be the the thin blue line crowd yeah you
know what i mean
and and it that definitely seems to be
at least wavering a little bit you know
because people are getting more and more
frustrated
and they're saying you know they've
tried everything they're opening their
business they're doing you know they're
they're trying to live their lives
they're trying to just not be bothered
and we're eight months in and there's
still police officers who are going
along with it so people are
you you're starting to get that
sentiment where people are getting a lot
less forgiving about
oh you're just following orders i mean i
think you're going to see more of it
you talked about some of these officers
being ignorant but i know a lot of
police officers that i
that i always say not knowing the law is
not an excuse for not following it
and and they need to really understand
here this is so counterintuitive we have
these decrees by a goldman sachs
executive who is now governor
that is telling you no gym no small
businesses
no working out no bettering yourself
meanwhile walmart liquor stores all of
them perfectly fine
but you're talking about you're in the
business of making people healthy
right you're in the business of making
people work out me and lydia just
started lifting literally like a week
ago
only once we're already hooked and
addicted to it because you feel
very good it feels amazing but but but i
i
you know and that's something that
people are deprived of
because of a goldman sachs executive
saying i know what's better for you and
they don't because if they did
they would have been talking about diet
nutrition sleep exercise
almost everything the opposite is so so
so what you brought up is something very
important
uh these officers need to know that
they're part of a larger
problem that they need to realize and
they need family and friends to come
together and shame them for from doing
the wrong thing
and following people who are doing bad
things i agree but i'll push back a
little bit i don't like the shaming
thing it's like a very left-wing thing
where they like
chant shame no you wanted a chungla
across their head
you know what is you know how it hurts
i'm talking about someone's grandma
bopping them on the head
lightly being like well dare you a
well-placed jungle will hurt yes but i'm
not i'm not saying
beat your kids i'm saying you got some
guys in his late 20s early 30s and his
grandma's like what did you do are you
nuts and then have him be like okay
well that's what i mean i agree with you
on that point you need more of that the
problem i see is there have been these
stories of like
leftist cafes where a cop will come in
and they'll be like get out we don't
serve your kind around here no cops
and the cops are like dude what i think
that's crazy
you know if it's like dude we i i we
need police
you know i think i think it was brett
weinstein who said uh uh you know a
civilized society requires
the police to be able to arrest people
okay and sometimes they make mistakes
and there are heirs
we have to sort through those things i
think when police brutality happens it's
horrible needs to be stopped i think
when police abuse their power we got to
call it out and we need some police
reform because there's issues where
i've seen i've seen way too many
examples of cops not being held
accountable
but i think it's insane if you go around
saying all cops are bad or whatever and
you know
to uh to my good friend michael malus i
mostly disagree
he says he said all cops are criminals
i've actually heard him re
uh what's the word uh recalibrate that
recalibration yes that's one way to
phrase it
uh that wasn't what i was gonna say like
on a show yeah he was saying
they're not all they're not all horrible
people i i was surprised to hear him say
because
because we had this conversation and my
thing is like there's a problem with the
culture there's a problem with people
freezing to hold him accountable
and you know for a long time i think
because the left
irrationally attacked cops with all the
riots especially
watching watching the minneapolis police
department be burned down and the cops
running for their lives as like riders
are storming the building and
torching it and then even portland where
they barricaded the front and back
so there was no way out and tried
burning the building down people inside
of it
i can sympathize with those officers
like dude that's crazy yeah i don't like
getting tickets either
you know but it's like come on man you
don't burn a building with people inside
it because you're mad that they're
giving fines people they have quotas
but then the issue is because of that i
see a lot of conservatives who are
defensive of police
who will say they're just overly so
right exactly so now it's
now it's changing though they threw the
blue lives the thin blue line flag on
the ground and stomped on it you know
yeah i mean i i've been speaking in dc
you know for all these
these past events and stuff bringing in
the small business aspect and
you're starting to see especially dc at
night when when antifa
and the proud boys tend to go at it you
know um
neither side is very appreciative of the
cops being there you know you're
you have the the leftist chant you know
that um
that all cops are are bad and then and
then you have
basically the right side saying you know
why are you protecting these people let
us take care of
it or you know and and why are you
defending the
you know the antifa you know why why are
you why are you holding us back and
they're they're getting increasingly
frustrated and i don't see it going
anywhere
except in that same direction in a
downward spiral where
they're going to be pitted between
everybody i you know
i i think it's it's there's a lot of
tribalism here
and i think you know like like we were
just saying you know a lot of a lot of
people on the right were very defensive
of cops
it was a cold wake-up call when the
conservatives were the ones getting
arrested and
smacked down you know
i've seen a lot of peaceful legitimate
leftist protests i like how they say you
know like 93
of all the protests were peaceful and
it's like okay okay i get it no but
there there were a lot i i've in my day
i've seen peaceful protests
i've seen the cops strike first i've
seen you know a cop walk up to a crowd
of people in ferguson and throw a
flashbang at him for no reason
there was no order there was no nobody
cared and they just started this and all
sudden boom everyone went crazy and
people were running and screaming and
then looters started looting in the
chaos
and i'm like why would they do that and
there's no accountability for that stuff
but
you're seeing that i say the logical
solution is well we need some reform
like we need to be able to call that out
journalists should film that guy there
should be video of it
instead we get a very extremist left
view that all cops everywhere always are
bad
burn down all the building which is
insane and then on the right you get
this overwhelming forgiveness
i'm worried about what's gonna happen
when police have no support and we
actually get a defund the police
movement that has no resistance
because i can't see conservatives being
like i'm gonna keep sticking up for
these people after my business was
destroyed
you know eventually the last time you're
gonna you're gonna lose support from
every side and then these same
politicians who have been chanting
defund the police are going to have
absolutely no opposition to it because
all rational thinking is just going to
go out the window because
everybody's emotional at that point and
then the politicians are going to do
what they do best and take advantage of
a situation
where people are pitted against each
other and they get to do whatever they
wanted to do anyway you see what
happened in minneapolis after they voted
to defund the police
yeah prime skyrockets crime skyrocketed
and they i think they actually had to do
a study as to figure out why
they started getting a bunch of phone
calls from angry constituents
saying why are people shooting outside
my eyes why is crime skyrocketing
and they and they ran back in and said
can we take this back and bring the
police back
they already lost a ton of officers who
quit because they were like you don't
support us we're getting out of here you
know we're done
and so now crime remains very high crime
is high across the board
but the cops that stayed they stayed
because they still had support
i can't imagine at this point i mean you
got to be crazy look at what happened in
new york city
you got to be crazy to live in new york
and support the police i'm sorry man
maybe maybe upstate new york but in new
york city the mayor
without any approval pla painted a
political slogan in the street
got a bunch of nypd to protect it and
actually arrest those who opposed it
and now they're lining up in front of
bars blocking people from walking into a
building
doing something similar to what you guys
did opening you know but not selling
stuff doing donations yeah i was
i was at max public house you went check
it out yeah i was there i actually i
spoke there
and went up to show my support to danny
and them and they had 20 those were
sheriffs
there's uh they're basically uh cuomo's
personal guard
i mean seriously because he had at that
point he had lost the support of the
nypd there was nypd driving by honking
their horns
wow they were driving up the street
honking their horns in support i could
support that um
which i thought was pretty cool but yeah
that was the sheriffs who were doing
that that day
yeah um but they i mean that's exactly
what they were they were there to
enforce his personal will
that's what it is there's no there's no
statutory law by which he can do this
in fact it flies in the face of the
constitution and every time him murphy
whitmer
you know wolf when they do these things
and then lose in the courts they just
well i'll do another one
and that's it snap their fingers okay oh
oh it's that you sued
and now my executive order has been you
know rescinded here's a new executive
order slightly different
or they just come at you with another
public institution they'll bring in the
health department they'll bring in the
zoning department
you know and they just move right onto
the next thing cuomo lost the support of
the nypd so he shifted to the
to the uh sheriffs newsom lost the the
support of the sheriff so he went with
the health department
health department he can control very
easily all right well i'll i'll tell you
this
you know we got a lot a lot to complain
about in terms of the destruction of the
economy but uh
well something's happening in europe
which is quite a bit different
germany is going to be placing people
who break quarantine
into detainment camps into either
refugee camps or detent detention
centers
anybody else get deja vu from that yeah
germany should be like the one place
that like where there's no camps
nothing not even summer camps
they need to wait until everyone else
decides no no at no point
should we be setting up internment camps
for things like this when you get to the
point where you're like we're going to
set up a relocation facility like you
got to stop and reflect on what it is
you're doing
all right because what's really fun
about the story let me show you the
story this is from the telegraph
germans who keep refusing to quarantine
could be put in detention centers under
new covert rules
in some german states where all other
options have been tried
authorities to detain those who refuse
to enter quarantine
so they mentioned there's a couple
different states like eastern state of
saxony
where hospitals have been struggling to
cope with one of the worst outbreaks
they have confirmed plans to hold
quarantine breakers in a fenced off
section
of a refugee camp what three further
states
baden wardenberg brandenburg and
schleswig holstein i'm not i can't speak
german
have also either already created such
facilities or in the process of doing so
a report in sunday's edition of welt
newspaper stated
in baden wurttemberg two hospitals will
have rooms reserved for repeat offenders
which will be guarded by police
brandenburg will use a section of a
refugee center
while shall swig holstein will use an
area within a juvenile detention center
well we're at the point now where
they're setting up the camps but uh
i i got i got i got a silence you know i
started this by saying
we got a lot to complain about but over
in europe it's getting bad well they're
proposing this
the same thing in new york state did you
hear about this yeah and there's
actually um
there's there's a whole study that was
put forth on the cdc website about this
and they called them green
zones um yeah you can pull that up
um it basically outlines a plan
to to section off areas of the country
and relocate people who are sick that's
on the cdc website
what the heck that's crazy why would you
put sick people together
and put people there why would you why
would you put people that you think
might be sick all together to make them
more
strict it's like four or five pages it's
it's well thought out they're talking
about
um if if the person who gets sent away
can't care for themselves then somebody
has to go with them so
you know if you have like an elderly
parent who's getting sent away you're up
for the camp as well
oh my gosh what's this called exactly
what was it this was on the cdc website
i think i may have found it let me see
if i'm i think they refer to them as
green
zones i will also point out on the cdc
website it specifically says there's
no evidence of covet existing in the
food supply
i looked at it up today and but another
thing you have to realize
is that the cdc the world health
organization they keep contradicting
themselves
non-stop 24 7. they told us that there
was no
uh human to human transmission no
transmission through
air they flip-flop on the mass they
flipped out on so many things it's very
hard to understand what they're saying
now another thing to really kind of
really consider here and it's kind of
worrisome
especially the news in germany because
they're really pushing this forward but
one of the things that they say is that
this is going to be specifically
for rule breakers what rules are we
talking about these are very
generalized language and when it comes
to the government's response to covid
a lot of the rules are arbitrary a lot
of them are made up
a lot of them have shown to have no
actual effect on stopping
uh the sickness the lockdowns have been
found in some instances to actually hurt
more people than help people
i i gotta tell you man for the people
listening just google search a picture
of murphy governor murphy of new jersey
and i got
i can tell you shield your eyes here's
no here's what i think i'm gonna give
you i'm gonna give you my
my my opinion on this okay you got this
guy ian smith how tall are you
six foot six foot and you're you're
pretty ripped man you work out
you run a gym once in a while you've got
a sweet beard beard
and you got the slick back hair i think
it's personal governor murphy
governor murphy i saw you and you're
like this dude this gym
and he went i want that no no when when
you when when the cop sided with you
i bet it was personal i bet he he
thought about himself and being a whiny
loser
and then here's the successful guy he's
running he probably couldn't get it up
that night that's probably what this is
all about
nerdy guy i really do think he was
personally insulted how dare you
challenge my power
the thing is he's been governor since
january 2018
and he's got massive amounts of power
yeah
way too much for one person yep well
well let's let's
he came in the door like that like like
just
overstepping almost right away let's
let's let's think about this
okay when i when i heard the story of
the cop who came up when you were
mentioning he said you're all in violent
violation of executive order that big
said have a nice day
i'm sure he got so mad like how dare you
i'm the governor you obey me and so he
made that call
threatening to furlough an entire
department unless they've been to his
whim
talk about a lunatic but think about
think about that level of depravity
i pulled up what you talked about this
is really interesting i have cdc.gov
right here and they say
interim operational considerations for
implementing the shielding approach to
prevent govind-19 infections
in humanitarian settings well hold on
guys shielding
that sounds pretty good right shielding
what does shielding mean they say
uh let's let's see what they say current
evidence indicates that older adults and
people of any age who have serious
underlying medical conditions
are at higher risk for severe severe
illness in most humanitarian settings
older population groups make up a small
percentage of the total population
for this reason the shielding approach
suggests physically separating high-risk
individuals from the general population
to prioritize the use of the limited
available resources
and avoid implementing long-term
containment measures among the general
population ah
let me break that down they're saying
we'll take the people who could get sick
and
we'll remove them from urban areas and
population centers
because we don't want to inconvenience
the general population now hold on
i did say protect the vulnerable allow
the you know
everyone ever to work i just don't like
the idea of
physically removing people from areas
yeah i'm talking about just like having
a building where it's like a sign on the
door saying
at risk for covid and then having
special precautions like you put the
package down they clean it before
bringing it in
not taking the people yeah you can put
like a symbol on their door
yeah that's that's something that hasn't
been tried in nazi germany yeah but
okay so what about armbands if you were
to put notes like that
and if you were to put a sign on
someone's store that said this person is
at risk of
developing covid please be extra careful
i don't think that's anything you could
put a little star david with a smiley
face next to it
i think it's disgusting i think if
you're going to single people out for a
a invisible uh disease a virus that we
think is out there
and then stuff them in concentration
camps that we're looking at 21st century
genocide we're looking at
the world war iii and we're declaring it
on ourselves
have you guys seen that movie song bird
you have you heard about it is that the
michael bay one where it's like 2024 and
kovid 23
is like mutated and everyone's locked
down it's an interesting movie because
the government's the bad guy in it and
that but that's the premise of the movie
is that there's these green zones
that eurozones cue zones okay so they
they cleverly renamed it from the cdc
website exactly
uh i think that's like the plot of it
right there well check it out check this
out so no i just pulled up the new york
state senate
assembly bill a416 now first let me just
say
it's only in committee the bill was
introduced it is in committee
it's not on the floor calendar it has
not passed the senate or the assembly
has not gone to the governor and has not
been signed this might just fizzle out
and die
but this bill basically says and look it
pertains to the removal and detention
of cases contacts and carriers who
are or may be a danger to public health
other orders provisions of the section
shall be utilized in the event if the
governor declares a state of health
emergency
due to an epidemic of any communicable
disease
any but here's my favorite part let's
say it's very broad language it says
it says cases or contacts that may be a
danger
that's what you got to read into what's
a contact that may be a danger
simple let's say you get an amazon
delivery a box on your hat on your
doorstep
you pick it up you open it and there's a
sonic bread knife yeah
and you press the button you can cut to
the bread we're getting one of those by
the
way
so let's let's see what you get you get
one of those carving knives you know
then someone shows up your door and it's
a little cuomo and he's like
you were in contact with a box
from someone who is sick therefore
you may be a danger and they'll detain
you what about the mailman
mail gets coveted everyone on the mail
route now well the thing you got to
understand here is that
the language here is very generalized
and there's going to be yeah it's done
like that many times because the
government could then look at this
little piece of paper and say well we
could interpret this
any which way we want and probably
because of
some privacy or hipaa laws you won't
even know if it's the mailman or if it's
somebody else
it'll be kept away from you and and the
thing that's really kind of scary here
actually is is that everything about
covid has been almost
political whether it's uh the alcohol
stores the gambling the walmart's costco
blm protest
the the lockdowns the selective uh
you know politicking of this entire
scenario we have seen it
bastardized and used and abused for
political power to the highest
extent what makes you think that this
higher authority that this government is
demanding from you
that it won't corrupt them to use it and
abuse it against
other political enemies i figured it out
ian why don't you
just while everyone's working out chant
hey hey ho ho
racism has got to go put up a black
lives matter banner
they won't touch it we thought about
that we thought about it
we thought about just smashing our own
windows in and
you would just run in and pick up some
dumbbells and then run out with them
that'd be great that was that was your
workout you were just moving things
no but i mean i like what would happen
if you actually just
invited some activists down i mean
here's the interesting thing look they
don't like cops
right and the cops the ones shutting you
down what if you just said hey black
lives matter do you want to have an
event here
they uh black lives matter got very
upset with me because
um the the local black
lives matter in in the philadelphia
south jersey area contacted me and told
me that
i needed to put a black square on my
profile um
because yeah um i was contacted by
more than one person saying you need to
do this because you have a voice
and we supported you opening um and i
said and that was
during the whole george floyd thing and
i said i don't know enough about this
situation to do that
and and i'm going to use my platform
because that was when my platform
started growing you know yeah once we
reopened i went on tucker carlson
i started to grow you know on social
media and then it was expected of me
to do that i hate it when people do it
they i if i invited them i don't think
they would come up
no you know what i mean i mean i can't
blame you because if someone comes to me
and says do this
you know you have to yeah i'm not going
to even if they're like if someone does
something for you and then they
expect something of you it's so
obnoxious right but you know what i
would say
i like i it's the saying is there's no
no there is there is no
no in business if someone comes to me
says i want you to do this i say okay
here are my terms
so if if someone came to me and said you
know black lives matter we want your
profile to be you know
black square i'd be like sounds good to
me well you guys show up we'll make a
big thing of it like
you'll come down to my my gym will open
up you guys will protest
and then i'll pull up my phone and i'll
do it and we'll high five how does that
sound
but what are the cops the captain bill
then then your gym's open you know what
i mean and then
you know i returned okay you got it you
know what i mean come down you support
us
protest the cops but i guess especially
the time you guys are trying to be
respectful
to the police yeah and we're going to
just exploit stuff i'm sorry i had the
fight with the governor to attend to i
didn't i didn't really have time for
you know being being everybody's
advocate i was trying to be an advocate
for small business yeah uh
and and myself and my family and that
was that was apparently unacceptable
i'm you know uh i don't know if you've
seen the uh the boogaloo boy stuff
like the boogaloo boys they're out and
they're with
black lives matter like there's black
lives matter person standing next to a
guy with the hawaiian shirt on or
whatever which is a change of tone
for the the boogaloo boys i don't think
so i don't know no not the boo
so there's there's a video from months
ago where
the boogaloo boys wearing their hawaiian
shirts and tactical vests and guns are
marching around with black lives matter
and then antifa this is this is crazy
video an anti-fog there's an antivo on
the left
boogaloo boys on the right and the ant
of a guy shakes the hand of the boogaloo
boy and says i know we don't agree but
you stood with you stood with us today
and for that we respect you
and the boogaloo boy says we agree with
you man we agree with you completely
we just we we all we don't like the
government so i think that's where we
can start
and they're together like which makes no
sense though because
i mean blm and and antifa
go running to the left and they you know
they they eat out of the hands of kamala
harris and
and the politicians on the left who who
pander to them
and the boogaloo boys do not go to the
right so so actually let's
let's do this let's jump to this story
and we'll we'll get into it we got this
from reuters annual pro-gun event at
virginia fizzles
in wake of u.s capital siege they say
only a few dozen gun rights activists
converge in the virginia
state capitol on monday for an annual
demonstration that typically draws
thousands
with this year's protests dampened by
tensions in the wake of the january 6
siege in the capital now i'm not
entirely sure they're right about this
sometimes what happens with these these
news stories when they talk about these
events this was published on at 6 15 a.m
but we actually have this tweet from
ryan devereaux
from 5 37 pm where you can clearly see
there's black panthers out there there's
proud boys
and there's boogaloo boys and the
interesting thing about it is ryan devro
tweets
heard a 20 year old boogaloo boy call a
passing group of proud boys quote
boot licking statist cucks the proud
boys dismissed the boogas anarchists
the original black panther party just
seemed happy to be there
so i guess look there there i don't know
if it's the same event maybe it must be
different i i thought it was the same
event so maybe i'm wrong about that
but there were still people coming out
and protesting in various in various
areas
what i find interesting about this story
is just how the boogaloo boys are an
entity unto themselves
they're basically just anarchists
so uh or libertarian types and growing
growing in in popularity
too you know so there's more and more
people who are starting to identify with
with
that but let's just throw the whole
government out but but you know
it's it's because i mean do you know
anybody who's happy with government
right now
no and right for good reason i mean you
can't blame these people for being
frustrated now i might not agree with
the hawaiian shirts and all that um yeah
right
but i mean we're we're rapidly
approaching that point where the whole
system is just broken like we're just
gonna have to throw the whole thing out
you know like it's
what did i mean thomas jefferson was he
the one who said every 200 years
you've got to like you know purge and
recycle or whatever well this group is
definitely interesting because it's hard
to kind of nail them down just a few
months ago the mainstream media was
talking about them being right wing
extremist but
they they are hyper critical of donald
trump they are hypercritical of
government officials
we saw in one particular state one of
the boogaloo boys had a trans flag
another person stood next to and was
with a black lives matter person and it
looked like they were all together
but another thing we really have to
understand here a lot of this is over
hyped by the mainstream media because if
you remember just a few days ago
we were hearing news reports fbi
warnings total fear-mongering paranoia
massive armed rallies happening this
weekend
all throughout the united states and all
the major capitals and what did we get
crickets
no like three guys five guys standing
around
five guys in new hampshire a couple guys
in virginia and now we had another rally
today in virginia that was separate out
of shape guys
some of them are out of shape some of
them are you know just look like they
you know they have shapes they're just
not
but but but today in virginia we saw the
biggest rally and we saw a bunch of
groups bunch of individuals
and this was the biggest one but again
everything was it was very peaceful
everything was
it was very calm they they came armed no
one got shot no one got hurt
thank goodness for that and it's the
opposite of everything that we've been
hearing on the mainstream media
about how there's a bloodbath coming and
they're still fear-mongering about this
at the u.s capitol
that literally i don't know why no one's
talking about this but it looks like the
the
washington dc is literally under
occupation right now and no one's
trying to even talk about green zones
and police checkpoints
and and and what in the world is
happening in the
that's ten times the amount of troops
that we have in iraq i read that today
we have about we have about 2500 to 3
000 in iraq
we have more troops we have 25 000 and
they're asking for 30.
why and hundreds of nypd officers
literally went down today to add
more security and assistance yes nypd
sent out from the boogaloo boys
exactly well this is this is this is the
thing there's so much this is what i did
a video on today specifically on the we
are change channel about this
active national security fear paranoia
state
that is absolutely ridiculous and there
and and when you see the mainstream
media coverage it looks like there's
going to be a huge conflict
but the only thing i'm seeing is people
saying hey stay home stay away from this
there might be a potential for a false
flag get away from there don't go there
but we're still being told by the
mainstream media that there's going to
be hell to pay
you know those 25 000 national guardsmen
all are being vetted to make sure that
they don't support donald trump too oil
changes yes
they're literally doing loyalty testing
there were some reports that the
democrats wanted to make sure that
any like the national guard who voted
for trump they'd vet or remove
weren't there i don't i don't know how
true that is i've seen this no no no
this was this originally came out from a
congressman
demanding this and now schumer and
pelosi officially came out
saying we want the dod to vet everyone
there
and we have the acting defense security
chief coming out and saying
there's no threat of an insider attack
like we've been hearing on the
mainstream media again but i mean
specifically
like are the democrats saying we want to
know who voted for trump or are they
saying
we want security assessments because i
heard reports that they were concerned
about national guardsmen who voted trump
as the starting point to actually look
into their backgrounds
yes yes and and that nancy pelosi came
out and i think said that and then they
also requested
and and i don't know if it ever went
through but i know that
somebody from congress requested that i
think it was nancy pelosi as well
that they'd be unarmed yeah i think i
heard that a lot of them have been on
arm
there's a lot of photos of them without
magazines in their rifles
so yeah right there they wanted to
disarm them which is interesting who
armed them in the first place
but this is this is what do you mean
twenty five thousand unarmed troops who
sent them no no but this is weird this
is weird
why are there 25 000 soldiers in dc
anyway who put them there
was it the democrats nancy pelosi saying
we're worried about this
vet them and disarm them i don't think
she's the one who put him there
i don't think the democrats the one who
who demanded 25 000
is this trump well there's a the way i
i would have explained the way i heard
it explained is just another vague term
saying these were federally mandated
soldiers that were sent there by the
federal government that's the vague
biggest language so that would be
commander-in-chief
then there was there was some retired
general said we haven't had this much
security since abraham lincoln
so so someone did this but it's just my
understanding is that it's the acting
secretary of defense who who deploys the
federal
uh national guard in the dc you know the
federal jurisdiction and he's a trump
guy so is trump the one who's like
send all of the troops
i don't know man because you know the
conspiracy theories are going crazy on
both the left and the right
the right is saying that trump has
created a prison that the democrats will
have to walk into in order to inaugurate
biden
and the left is saying because they're
that stupid yeah well yeah right
that's the conspiracy theory but the
left has basically the same conspiracy
theory
that donald trump is gonna box the
democrat
it's it's it's they believe very much
similar almost like one person's making
both of them up and just sending them
through the message board and stuff
yeah one one side's going donald trump's
gonna do it hooray
the other side's going then he goes
through the left and goes donald trump's
gonna do it oh no this is from uh the
babylon bee
not newsguarded it's a satire website
the most popular president in history to
be inaugurated in secret behind giant
wall guarded by thousands of soldiers
yes which as as fake as that is it's
not it's also true by the numbers i mean
he got the most votes of any president
well another thing to really consider
here is that before the raid on the
capitol we had warnings from the fbi the
nypd the capitol police that something
major was going to happen at the capitol
and then what happened they were mainly
unprepared now we're getting
no specific warnings the acting defense
secretary said
there's no intelligence of any upcoming
attack or threat
but yet they're over prepared that's
that's there's a crisis
there's a conspiracy theory too little
too late too much too late excuse me
this is this is the ongoing conspiracy
theory let me just start by saying dude
like january 20th is going to come and
go i really don't see anything happening
i'll admit this is all very weird stuff
we are well outside the confines of
what's considered normal
but the conspiracy theory right now is
that donald trump
needed an excuse to mobilize the
national guard in dc
in an unprecedented manner and if he
just did this
the democrats would scream he's staging
a coup trump deploying 25 000
fully armed with authorization freeze of
lethal force
into dc for no reason the democrats
would be like this is insane
trump staging a coup but what happened
was trump supporters thrown into the
capital
the democrats demanded securian were
shocked so then trump went
okay and got his 25 000. i don't believe
it's on purpose
you know this is this is the current
iteration of the conspiracy and i these
q people are
you know posting online saying just you
you'll wait and see trump's gonna do
something trump's not gonna do anything
nothing's gonna happen
biden's gonna be president four years of
let's wait and see right right right any
day now they choose but that's
that's what that's that's their current
conspiracy i will say
it's easy to understand why they believe
it because it is
none of it makes any sense right it's
really strange what's going on it's a
james bond movie
so well so some some other people i uh
you know have been posting that they
think
it's just the democrats an excuse it's
the establishment saying oh no look what
we had to do because of trump supporters
more funding
and we needed to because what would have
happened if they weren't there
more money more security more spying etc
you know what it
it looks like to me like the start of
a police state where there's part of
there's a
there's a constant level of fear like
you were just talking about in the media
where
there's always some impending doom upon
you so
you have to listen to what the
government says yeah there's always some
restriction on movement there's always
some
looming threat that you have to be
defended against and what a way to kick
off four years of that with 25 000
troops
in the nation's capital in an
unprecedented rollout of military force
during an inauguration where
nobody is going to show up you know i
i've mentioned this a million times so
for those that are listening forgive me
but i want to say it for for for you ian
because we never talked about it
that what people don't realize when it
comes to staging a coup they move
they imagine it'll be like a movie where
there's going to be like trump going
order the troops to stop biden make me
president and the troops just listen
when in reality a coup actually looks
very simple it's not the soldiers have
any idea what's going on
it would just be their commanding
officer or the pentagon saying hey
go surround the white house lock it down
there's some security threats and then
they would
if donald trump wanted to stage a
military coup and use the military to
seize power and stop the inauguration
they wouldn't tell the national guard to
do that they would tell them
stand here and don't let anyone pass
that's it
so i think if there was a real potential
for a coup
it would look exactly like this exactly
the soldiers just being like i don't
know i was told to stand here yep
you're not wrong and a lot of the uh
soldiers that are being interviewed
they're asked what are you doing here
what are you protecting
and uh according to michael tracy and
the reporting he's doing down there
he's like well one of them just told me
i don't know i'm just doing what i'm
told
and that's a lot of the scary customers
are doing there's a meme going around
that i tweeted right now that i think
uh hits the nail on the head with our
conversation here and it shows
all the troops sleeping together in the
capital not social distancing
and and the headline is if 25 000 troops
can do this
you can do this and below it is a
picture of four people having a nice
meal at a restaurant
so i think that's another thing that
people really need to kind of understand
here
if we're going through this huge
pandemic we're going through this huge
health scare
why is the government punishing you for
for trying to be in a gym or in a
restaurant meanwhile there's so many
troops
sleeping on a marvel sleeping on the
marble floor why would the government
risk the national guard during a
pandemic yeah okay i get it you want to
protect the elderly right well
the national guard is one of our first
lines of defense
cramming them all in the capitol
building sleeping with each other
my capital was attacked from the air by
a foreign nation on the inauguration
part all there
brought that up today it's a it's a very
good point why would you put that many
people
in in harm's way if you're cons if
you're if you're
so if you're so afraid of of this
looming threat
why would you put such a massive forces
in harm's way they're using them like a
fence to to keep the water out to keep
them flooded or they're trying to build
a wall of humans to
to protect but we're in a drought it's
because the elites use your children as
cannon fodder
or sandbags in this scenario i guess
like they're probably going to put them
on every street
and in every block corner and that's why
there's so many of them they have a
history
they have authorization for use of
lethal forms why
wait with what though it's the future
they're really
last i checked they were fully kitted
okay they were
given authorization for use of lethal
force and the democrats were like nah
we don't we don't want them to have guns
like this so
i don't know exactly where we're at
right now but why was that ever a thing
yeah what what's going on
yeah you know what i mean another thing
to consider is if you're in the military
you're commanding officers and your
politicians don't give a damn about you
and if they tell you to sleep on the
marble floor surrounded by
hundreds of people during a pandemic
you're gonna do it because you're gonna
do what you're told
and i think i just saw today that
finally there was some cots delivered
but most of them are still sleeping and
using the few limited restrooms
inside of the capitol building i mean
imagine being a soldier and just like
yep you're going to be inside the
capitol
for what what this paranoia this fear
that's that's again
totally made up not a real security
threat
when they had the security threats they
didn't listen to them now there's no
security threats according to them
officially
but yet we're still going through this
huge security theater
in order to i i think it's a it's a
larger virtual signal for the bigger
police state that they're trying to
to uh boast about in everyone's face
so here's the story from the 14th
national guard at capital authorized to
use lethal force and aftermath of mob
they say on january 12 2021 national
guardsmen were given authorization to be
armed in support of the u.s capitol
to protect the u.s capitol and
individual members of congress and their
staff
according to a statement from the dc
guard they go on to say a defense
official confirmed the authorization
includes permission for guards
guard troops to use lethal force
so there there's pictures of them
carrying their guns
and i i believe the national guard they
have full auto don't they don't they
have selected
fire yeah of course that's i'm just i'm
just kind of weirded out by the whole
thing
we're all going to be watching or we're
all supposed to be watching this
inauguration and you're going to see
this military-style inauguration this
police state
totally like it just it screams or well
i mean it's
it's all of it yeah it's very it's very
very very peculiar and
the the crazy part is the the media just
just
ratchets the fear we get no explanation
as to why we get the only information
that we get are from the
few journalists who actually put some
good stuff out but it's just be afraid
to shut up
the mainstream media is showing no
apprehension against an actual police
state an actual lockdown
an actual you know checkpoint set up
green zone set up the militarization of
the
cities of the of the entire country's
capital
and yet no muck breaking no real
journalism no
no no questions about it at all that's
another thing
that that has you thinking because they
were warning they were screaming about
fascism about totalitarianism coming
under donald trump
but now it's coming in as it looks very
symbolically
under joe biden right in front of our
face and they're marching around
lock into locking everything down the
barbed wire set up like they're
literally about to face a
horde of zombies that's it's it's like
it's like watching day z
happening right now it's like it's like
that's what they're preparing for i
don't know maybe there's something else
happening that we don't know about
i don't think so but i think this is a
larger virtue signal
i think this is this is the them saying
look at us
look how powerful we are don't mess with
us because we have all
these police officers all these national
guard that will do whatever we tell them
to do and they will back us and you
can't fight us because of look how many
soldiers
we have behind us which is that's what's
happening perfect follow-up to the
to the capitol which is like you know
they had this little incident at the
capitol that they've blown
hugely out of proportion based on a lot
of half-truths and and
misinformation and then now they turn
around a couple weeks later and say
try it again it's like you tickle the
nose of the dragon and the whole body
goes flailing
like they went in and they they they got
the congress people like
aoc said she was afraid for her life she
said she narrowly escaped death yeah so
they're
they're twisted with fear right now yes
do you see the video of the shaman
walking in
chambers with the mall cop behind him
and there's a
there's a guy sitting down on the phone
and the shaman guy goes like hey man
good to see you he's like oh that guy is
bleeding
and the cops like you need medical
attention he goes i'm fine and then the
mall cop guy goes
any chance i could get you guys to leave
and they were like we're leaving we're
leaving
and the one guy goes don't worry man i'm
making sure nobody messes with anything
he's like all right thanks because this
is like the sacred most sacred place
like an insurrection of a bunch of like
just dumb people standing around
i get it storming the capital was dumb
but you saw the videos of people cops
letting people in
oh yeah i mean it it was all over with
it it was basically a guided tour
yeah a lot of the cop there's one video
where the cops like disagree with it but
agree with your right to protest
there's a war right passing me let's
amend there is a zero percent chance of
insurrection there was a zero percent
chance of them being able to overthrow
overturn the government so calling it a
coup d'etat is absolutely disingenuous
and it's an absolute lie
i love how they're trying to act like
there's ever a possibility that
occupying a building would overthrow the
government
like it's it's not 1600s anymore you
know what i mean like
they they storm the vault they control
the government papers now they're the
government but no their word
works congress people were in that
building as far as i know so
if they if they had wanted to go in
there and destroy those people they
probably could have and that still
wouldn't change anything so there's the
line of succession
and then you know look if god forbid
they actually did horrible things to
members of congress
yeah it would they're not gonna it would
just be
indictments there would be charges of
sedition but it never happened like
where a bunch of congress people were
killed
in a day in a riot in the united states
that's never what i'm saying is that
there's there was
no scenario where this was an
insurrection okay i mean hold on
i guess maybe you could call it that if
it was like
the the i don't know it's a major
stretch
well i don't think that was their
intention attempted insurrection maybe
but there was never a possibility
it would do anything there's zero
possibility the government was
anywhere in danger of being overthrown
period yeah trump has no institutional
power
mike pence was even against him so when
we're talking about the chances here
let's be real here let's be honest yes
there's some bad actors yes there are
some violent people let's call it out
you know however you may want to call it
out but but when we learn
when we're looking at everything this is
this is just security theater in a
hyperbolic response to it
that that is definitely disproportionate
to say the least from my own personality
the question is who sent the the armed
guards there
the democrats do it because they
genuinely believe as a threat
or they want the optics well they seem
to be kind of upset by it and the
national guard follows the orders of
trump
for now there's two more days actually i
think we got about
a day and a half maybe you start the
countdown oh yeah many
immediate many media organizations have
they literally have countdowns
let me get one just before even coming
on the show i saw a friend
that was flying into dc and she talked
about how
after coming out of the tsa she had to
go through
two other personal screenings they
looked through
all of her personal possessions in her
bags and there was police officers
literally at the gate watching everyone
come in
so the the security for even flying into
washington dc is
absolutely utterly ridiculous so
um again no threat as as so far that we
know of that's legitimate so so what is
going on here
well so we we have the countdown we have
it right here on the it's a daily mail
right on top 38 hours 54 minutes
uh now 53 minutes and we also have the
story
biden blocks trump's bid to lift ban on
visitors from the uk
brazil and europe and says he will
strengthen travel restrictions
dashing hopes of millions who haven't
been able to fly to the us
since march all those people who voted
for biden
thinking they were going to get
something good out of this it's not
going to happen
it's only going to be worse under joe
biden maybe not totally
i think he's going to diminish student
loan debt he says he's going to
there's no diminishing student loan debt
there's stealing passengers
they're stealing someone else's money
and paying for someone's bad choices and
mistakes are they not just
not paying back the the loan agencies
they're paying uh
always get their money dude if they're
going to tax us to pay the loans that's
exactly right
that's exactly that's how government
works
don't pay them back man that's insidious
that they're charging kids
interest it doesn't work you have to not
not in america doesn't work like that
every
every banker always always gets their
due yeah that's that's the first rule of
of finance in america
so it makes no sense we're we're talking
a lot about you know there's lockdowns
and
and a few minutes ago we were talking
about what you're allowed to know and so
reminding me of the story i want to pull
this up and get you guys comments on it
it's from this from sarahcarter.com
sarah carter show
cnn segment discusses removing
conservative media and forcing everyone
into the quote
same conceptual reality in this segment
with brian styles on reliable sources
a former facebook i think i think as a
facebook executive says that they need
to basically treat conservatives like
they did isis
and start isolating and removing them my
favorite
my favorite quote is when this guy says
there are people on youtube for example
that have a larger audience than daytime
cnn
huh that's right there's actually a ton
of youtube channels
it sounds like eliminating the
competition it does exactly
exactly it's funny i'm pretty sure
the overwhelming majority of career
youtube channels get better ratings than
cnn
like i'm sure okay there's there's a lot
of small youtube channels but
if you have oh geez if you have a couple
hundred thousand subscribers on youtube
you're probably doing better than cnn in
the key demo right and if you're if
you're a channel with a million subs or
more you're
definitely so it's basically every
single channel i'm
i'm pretty sure like kyle kalinski jimmy
door and david pakman are beating cnn
but cnn's not targeting the left
channels they're targeting the right
wing channels
cnn staff cnn uh i don't call the guy a
reporter
oh in a resident extremist zealot
oliver darcy is reaching out to cable
providers
to get fox news on and newsmax banned
from their networks from their
from from the cable subscriptions you
can't even buy it they want to get
pulled
it's a whole new level of lunacy
and censorship because they're not going
to stop at twitter right we
project veritas put out this video clip
where we can see they're talking about
banning more and more people
they're not going to stop there because
their bread and butter is
screaming in your face that's what they
do
that i i love how they used to rag on
fox news saying fox news are just
scaring old people
well i tell you what cnn does college
kids yeah
when i turn on cnn you know the only
thing i i imagine is
don lemon going oh and brian so they're
like
that's the whole thing and i'm like just
sitting there going like ah that's
that's what cnn is and so what happens
when they've already banned everybody
right so they say they banned 70 000 q
anon related
individuals they banned donald trump uh
oh
what's oliver darcy going to do be out
of a job they already fired jim acosta
he's no longer at the white house
anymore
he's doing beat reporting now i guess so
uh oliver dawson says
fox news let's get them banned and they
won't stop
they'll keep going eventually some
powerful people are starting losing
money and maybe then they'll wake up and
realize what's going on
i gotta say when we were when we
i guess you could say the us government
removed a segment of the bath party of
of hussein's
iraqi cabinet and hundreds of i don't
even thousands of people were removed
from the workforce and not allowed to
work
that caused the formation of isis when
you remove people from the workforce and
won't allow them to enter it
they will form a new organization and
those people in iraq got violent
so i get that they're trying to go after
preventing isis but if they
if they do this and they ban all these
people there's a chance that
that we're going to create something
like isis in the united states ian hold
on
from the washington times trump
supporters likened to nazis and saddam's
bath party
in cable news demon demonization duel
cuomo and don lemon they're they're
talking exactly
read history and understand the
formation of isis you know what
it it seems to me that this is kind of
what they want though
they they want to keep pushing people
until they can they can make them do
something
radical so they're essentially
radicalizing people they're pushing them
pushing them pushing and pushing them
they're not giving them any any remedy
to these to these oppressive measures
and then
eventually like you said if you remove
people you're going to create this
vacuum where something else forms and
and usually
in that in in that case is something
ugly and you're going to start to
radicalize people but that's
i i call me crazy but then you get your
hey they're domestic terrorists well
these angry people here they're domestic
terrorists now now we need to get them
out
that's what isis was there's another
created and then we had something to
fight
there's another way to look at it it's
not that the people are being
radicalized it's that oliver darcy
is radicalized okay so again for those
that have heard me talk about my other
channels
darcy interviewed me several years ago
when i said
banning the alt-right for their opinions
is dangerous free speech means even the
speech we don't like
this guy working for business insider
was like what an interesting thought i
should highlight this for a story
where am i today four years later same
exact position
i have not moved i still believe in free
speech even for speech i don't like
and i'll argue against it but the only
thing let it be spoken
where has he gone since that that four
years ago when he interviewed me
he's now the cheerleader most high
profile like the highest profile
activist extremist trying to get
private companies that can do whatever
they want to ban
access to certain news channels he
doesn't like so it's not that the people
in the middle have become extreme it's
that oliver darcy shot so far left
from his point of view there's a bunch
of far-right extremists
far right from him and he's he's too
radicalized to realize
that he's the one who's been pushed to
the extreme yeah well
exactly the they're they're taking a
hard left
um and and in doing so these people that
are
regular normal everyday people who fall
moderate right or even moderate left
now in in order to defend your position
right because in in politics we always
tend to compromise
in order to defend that position they
have to
pull hard to the right or they're going
to lose ground you know because if you
start compromising with
somebody who's going far left and you're
still
arguing the middle road you're gonna
wind up that's what's happening
you're gonna wind up there unless you
you start to
pull back harder yeah and it's but
what's happening is that
conservatives and moderates regular
americans
aren't becoming extreme they're they're
in fact policing the extremes of the
right
they are you look at uh steve king when
he made comments about what positive
comments about white nationalism they
pulled him off all his committees
and then he got primaried in the by the
republican party and he's out
and now they because the republicans
were like we don't want none of that and
the moderates are like all right that's
cool
the left doesn't do that so they don't
so as long as conservatives keep trying
to be reasonable and play by the rules
and the left won't
you're always you're always going to
lose ground you're kind of like a
leftist that's
trying to keep the left from going crazy
right
well well i would just i would disagree
with you tim i think oliver darcy is
doing
god's work i think all all information
should be conformed and unified by
special interest
talking points by the richest people in
our society who know what's best for us
and i think it's great that they already
on youtube are promoted an
algorithm when you search news you see
them first the next video that usually
plays is them
whatever you're watching i think it's
great that they have this unfair market
competition
since they know what's best for you and
where would we all be
if it wasn't for cnn's top article today
on cnn politics
about i'm not kidding you this is this
is the headline here
cnn released an article saying this is
joe biden's
inauguration party playlist that you're
gonna play
for your inauguration yeah i didn't
listen though
yeah they're literally releasing the
playlist
for you to celebrate joe biden's
inauguration give me a couple of
what were they i didn't know we could
find a way i don't know about the one
you had from today but i do have joe
biden and kamal harris drop a playlist
for your inauguration watch party
that's it yeah where would we be if we
didn't have hard-hitting
real news like this uh that's forced
jammed down our throats where
hold on hold on don't you want to be
lulled into a calming ignorant sleep
yes i want to play my music and
celebrate the poor old man who doesn't
know where he is
he's represented by all the special
interests it's bliss
yeah you know listen listen let me ask
you a question if there was a meteor
or a comet or whatever about to rip
through the earth and just
wipe it out no no no that's too quick
let's say it's like a it's like a giant
it's an asteroid or meteor about to hit
the earth and when it does
and you'll have three minutes left to
live as you watch the fireball
coming towards you would you rather
watch and know it's happening or would
you rather be
chilling in your basement headphones on
playing skyrim or something no i want to
get it i want to i want a good seat
i crack a beer and just be like maybe
the sd card will survive
that's kind of how i'm going to watch
the inauguration actually
staring at the sunset like it's the end
yes
no but i mean look a lot of people would
prefer to be in the basement headphones
on playing through games totally
ignorant to the world collapsing around
them and just be vaporized instantly
there's a lot of people not me i'm not
one of i it's almost like it's like you
know in the matrix you know which pill
do you want a lot of people
would be like nah i'm gonna take the
blue pill i don't wanna i can't do the
head in the same thing it's part of why
this
this covet in the food supply thing is
driving me insane because i think that
it's it's
a hard cognitive dissonance for people
to think that maybe the the animal
fat that they're eating the meat and the
cheese and the the cream the milk is
gonna contain that stuff or hyper
exacerbate
its growth in your system and
dear god don't stick your head in the
sand it's right in front of us yeah well
they want to keep
you afraid they want to keep you in a
state where you're at a low vibrational
kind of energetic field where you're
always panicking always freaking out and
and when you're in that kind of highly
emotional state you're very easily to be
manipulated
you're very easily able to be controlled
by other people coming in and saying
i have the perfect solution i'll keep
you safe look how strong i am look how
many national guardsmen i have behind me
i know it's better for you if you just
give me everything you have and that's
exactly what's happening right now
with this latest move by joe biden
blocking people from traveling
there's going to be more blocking
there's going to be more lockdowns and
there's going to be more division pushed
on by the mainstream media that wants to
keep you in this fierce state of
the average common man they want you
afraid of your neighbor
and another thing that i wanted to
address when you guys were talking
before
about this larger division issue the
washington post
literally released a piece about
multi-racial whiteness
trying to explain how people of color
voted for and supported donald trump so
he used enrique from
the proud boys as the photo they're
making up new terms
to represent whiteness which is again
just
in their lexicon right now that they use
as a little pinata
that they beat the crap out of since
they get candy out of because so many
few people
are afraid to stand up for each other
and and they're getting away with this
essentially because of our acquiescence
and our participation in the fear and
hatred of one another
what's so it's so insidious about that
article
is that what they're doing with saying
multi-racial whiteness
is that whiteness represents negative
traits
of people which has been going on for a
long time it's been going on for a long
time but what they're doing is they're
saying
these negative behaviors are inherent to
white people
and non-white people can have these
behaviors too you see what they're doing
they're basically they're not saying
that people are white they're saying
whiteness is is just a word that
represents
bad right exactly so so there you go
supremacy white supremacy all that
stupid nonsense which makes no sense
especially when you see the boogaloo
boys
there's a video of these people in dc i
think it's in dc i'm not sure
no maybe maybe it's richmond and they're
talking to boogaloo boys and they're
like
you were you were with white
supremacists and they're like no we're
not we've never been like yeah
you were down there in dc during the six
and they're like no we weren't
they were boogaloo boys they're wearing
hawaiian shirts and they're like that's
not us which there was what two million
people in dc it was every single one of
those a white supremist yes you know
because
i was there and i saw saw a lot of
multiracial whiteness down there
yeah and it's that's that it's so absurd
that that even gets passed like like
who who who reads that and actually
looks at that and says yeah yeah really
really this is this is hard hitting
hard hitting drama people i'm afraid
like corey bush
i gotta meet her because i've been
reading her twitter and she's so racist
she's she's nuts she's it's not about
being racist about
she's an extremist she's an extreme so
listen
what is an extremist everybody will give
you definition i'll give you my simple
definition
a moderate a a a pragmatist a stoic
rational a leftist a right-wing
individual are not necessarily
extremists
a leftist will say something like i
believe in universal health care
and you know uh workers work worker
control of the means of production to
varying degrees
let's have a conversation about
implementing this a free market
capitalist or ncap is not an extremist
they'll say
i believe in the free market let's have
a conversation about how i'm moving that
direction
what people like corey bush say is expel
all of the republicans who dared speak
up
you know uh in defense of donald trump
that's extremism
an extremist says we must have communism
by any means necessary that's extreme
she is very very extreme yeah it hurts
pin tweet is expel the republican
members of congress who incited the
white supremacist
attempted coup that's insane and so
you know what's funny is they they like
to rag on the cuban on members of
congress or whatever and i'm like
sure but show now complain about the
extremist
conspiracy conspiracist democrats
they're there there's no white
supremacist conspiracy going on it's not
real but they live in a paranoid
delusional state
and the media props it up there's
probably there's a class conspiracy
where people very wealthy people want to
stay wealthy and they're okay with
leaving poor people poor
there is that that does exist well it's
always been about that but they
they and then they they bring the racism
element in to keep
the lower socioeconomic status is
fighting amongst each other instead of
looking
at where the actual problem because the
only oppression is socioeconomic
oppression you know in this country
yeah of course you're going to have your
outliers but the majority of people
don't experience racism on a daily basis
but
even if you look at the institutions
that cause pain suffering
poverty inequality it's not your
neighbor that believes in a different
political opinion than you
it's a larger institution that's telling
you the problem is your dna
your melatonin that's the issue right
there
yeah and and they convinced people that
somehow this is justified which is
absolutely ridiculous it's insane and
it's driving us down a slippery slope
where
we're we are fighting each other instead
of realizing the bigger picture right in
front of well it's it's
it was conveniently around occupy wall
street yeah i was just thinking that
yeah we
we've talked about it quite a bit the
bankers were were packing their bags
they were ready they were like the jig
is up they're gonna they're gonna audit
the federal reserve we're done
warren buffett was giving away a ton of
giving away i'll do air quote ton of
money
mark zuckerberg donated i'm doing air
quotes tons of money
and it wasn't because they had a change
of heart in like the grinch his heart
grew you know three sizes that day was
because they were like
when the pitchforks come out it's coming
for us conveniently people like mark
zuckerberg
who were in control of social media
started feeding identity politics to
everybody
and then there are people who don't like
being insulted based on race
and there are people who like insulting
based on race and boy did they whip them
into a ludicrous
there was a little bit of of like racist
or identity politics at occupy and then
like the news organization was like oh
that's good
get that get that white guy says
something something about black guy put
run with that one well they've always
seen and you don't see because
no no it's because these i i think it's
more a generational thing i don't think
was necessarily like a rich guy snapped
his fingers and said you know aha
identity politics is a solution
i think it's that this millennial
younger millennial generation
have been raised into this cult probably
going you know influenced very heavily
by colleges
and now they believe an insane cult-like
dogma that
doesn't make sense at all in the middle
east
they try to make us afraid of brown
people with this stupid
muslim attack in the middle east it was
all about let's go after the muslims
like 911 the afghanis iraq it's the
muslims there's this muslim fear
a scapegoat it's always a scapegoat yeah
you can just follow that all the way
back you can follow that to germany you
can follow that to the russians
but everybody look even even trump was
was was finding his
target you know audience and what he was
concerned about current concerned about
you know immigration is a problem
islamic terror is a problem and people
were scared of these things
and so he used them my issue is that
they say donald trump is a
is a uh what do they say he was uh
what's the word i'm thinking of
i can't think of the word a lot of words
demagogue he was choosing and singling
out these people
as the problem i'm like so are you you
you lo
you crazy crazy people the hypocrisy of
the of the left never ends i mean that's
that's that's their calling card is is
they double standard yeah they'll call
you out on it and then they'll do the
exact same thing
in the next sentence i know the problem
is when trump would say something
like we're gonna have a muslim ban in
this country and they're like ah he
admitted it
and then he like changed it so that
there's like there's actually other
countries in the band it was a
recommendation from the obama
administration
republicans criticize him you got uh
you you get you get criticism from
various republicans being like i don't
agree with donald trump how did he say
these things
and the left meanwhile does literally
the same thing and
no one calls them out they don't break
ranks no they don't the right does
all the time dude people were so afraid
of
muslims in like two thousand yeah they
were yep
that's deep in the psychology of the of
the people that are 20 years old today
they were born into it like it was
normal oh now they're running for
congress and like making these weird
laws and there's this reverse
racism stuff well no no the people who
are scared of muslims aren't the left
i don't know who it is anymore it was
all of us the last i mean i wasn't no no
the left are the people who heard
you saying that right now and we're like
i have to stop these nazi republicans
who hate muslims
they hear you saying that and they grow
up thinking if only i could stop the
racists
we're like the multitude with racism
right with with worse racism
yeah that's that's the best part of it
is their solution is always the problem
in and of itself
yeah the house is on fire quick throw
fuel into it we used to turn it down
completely we would like sit at taco
bell as teenagers and talk about reverse
racism we talk about like um
there's no such thing as we're i know
there's not and it's just racist
there was when i was a kid i was like
okay affirmative action is allowing
just black people to get jobs that
they're not qualified for
so that's a form of reverse racism
against hold on hold on hold on and we
would get so angry about it no no no no
hold on
that's not affirmative action i got in
the 90s was that not affirmative action
is not that someone who's not qualified
is getting a job they would give it
based on race and not quite not
qualifications
they would they would move down the the
list of qualified people until they
found a certain race certain quote
there are certain quotas oh yeah yeah so
yours was a little little harsh in doing
that
and doing that they would bypass you you
run open
the or you you open up the possibility
that you will skip somebody
who is more qualified because you have a
quota to me so it's
it's it's a side effect of of what it's
what's a good i mean i think that policy
comes from a good place but
it's one of those things that it sounds
better as an idea
and you can't execute it without well
look the the path to hell is paid with
good intentions you know always
so so here's the way it would work let's
save a hundred people and they all take
a naturix exam
and the top ten are mostly white people
because the united states is mostly
white
they would say okay the one two okay
white person white person white person
okay we're gonna skip all these where's
the first
latino ah there we go seven he gets the
first slot
so now you've skipped six qualified
individuals in fact
more qualified because you wanna have a
race in
you know a particular race in your
system i know now that
because of slavery a lot of
african-americans were dumped into our
economy with zero and so there was this
higher
wealth uh bracket for the the people
that weren't african-american you know
lighter skin
but and so they're more educated by
because of the autonomy
i know that now but don't forget the end
of slavery wasn't the end of the
problems
because they were like th the south
after the civil war
didn't want to be occupied by the north
so they did everything in their power to
obstruct
the the 13th 14th 15th amendments the
right to vote
there absolutely was tons of racist
policies all the way up into jim crow in
the civil rights era
and that was all the democrats mind you
which is kind of funny and now
the same political party that pushed
racism
is pushing racism again today do you
think we'll get past maybe this is kind
of
an open question that we'll get past the
racism
when we stop listening to politicians
yeah i think your average everyday
person doesn't give
a [ __ ] what color you are i think i
think that's a pretty broad statement
but i think that applies to most people
and i think that the fairest statement
ever ever said about trump was that he
doesn't care
whether you're white black latino gay
straight he cares if you can make it
money
to clarify you you said ship like you
know a vessel on
water correct yeah yeah okay very very
good but
but but it's too much race is too much
of an effective
divider uh by the elites that that's
been working for them very well and as
you said sp if people stop
paying attention to all the people
pushing it on us and actually being
racist i think then it could finally
work and i think
there's a very small window but it's one
of the biggest effective
battering battering rams against the
populations from actually realizing that
they have a lot more in common
than they do could we potentially end on
a positive note and talk about what's
happening in tunisia holland and denmark
with all the protests
as well as the bigger movements in italy
and poland the mass
riots and mass arrests well on a
positive note showing that you know in
in italy and poland
there's people coming together and
saying enough of these lockdowns we're
going
to open up in unison where there's too
many of us where you can't shut us all
down
i think that's a positive step and uh
regarding what's happening
in denmark there's been a lot of
protests against the lockdowns
uh that that are huge but yet have not
garnered a lot of media attention which
which is why i think we should talk
about them on a kind of
lighter more positive note that there is
some kind of
you want you want to talk positive you
know we're going to have to like
try hard to find a story from a news
outlet mo because look even if we want
to be positive on what's going on with
covid
the story we have here from dw from uh
about tunisia
600 people arrested the army has been
deployed after violent protests these
people
are frustrated over what's going on the
lockdowns and so they're coming out
and the state's coming out and beating
600 people that's a massive arrest
in the netherlands 142 people got
arrested so
sure i guess there's an optimism there's
a hope
people are starting to say enough of
this standing up and saying
it didn't work it's not working and we
will not suffer
any longer that's good that you know it
gives me hope when i see people standing
up what they believe in it is
but there's a crackdown from the state
across the board and i don't i don't
know if we have any reason to believe
that they're going to give in to the
demands of these angry individuals
yes but we can't give up all hope and i
think when we
see these issues we have to cover them
honestly and fairly
so maybe my wording wasn't the best in
in that particular instant and involved
a lot of personal stuff from what i've
seen throughout last year and what's
unfolding this year but but you know
talking about your story
you're still kicking you're still
pushing forward and and i think
i think you should answer this question
more than me since of course
you're still fighting the fight rather
than us just kind of calling it
and observing it i i am optimistic
actually you know i i've i've been doing
this alongside my partner frank for
eight months now you know we opened on
may 18th
you know so pretty much eight months to
the day um
and there is a growing sense of
rebellion
and a growing sense of defiance
from everybody um
you know when we first opened up we had
a ton of support
more support than we ever imagined but
it was mainly from the right
it was mainly trump supporters it was
mainly
um conservatives libertarians um
you know constitutionalists that support
as this has gone on has intensified with
those people
but also broadened um the people
you know when we first opened who just
really weren't interested in the story
or
didn't think it was that important at
the time started to get involved
um and then as this has continued to
draw out
we've gotten a lot of support from
people who are typically moderate lefts
and even people who identify a little
bit
you know harder to the left i tell the
story a lot i had a guy come into the
to the gym bought a t-shirt and
you know i'm packing it up for him and i
said thank you for your support
and he uh he looked at me and he said i
want you i want to be honest with you
and i said sure he said in the beginning
of this
i thought you and frank were were
wrong you know to to say it nicely he
didn't say it so nicely
um he said i thought you guys were
greedy i thought you were doing it for
your own selfish reasons
i thought you were you were being
careless um and i
and and you really pissed me off and he
said the only reason i followed the
story was because
you really pissed me off and he said i
trash talked to you online you know
any any negative article i could find i
would share it i would you know
argue in your comment section and he
said i'm here today because i've watched
this
continue for five months now or whatever
it was
and he said i support you he said and
i'm still a democrat i'm
you know he said he said i think at the
time he said i'm still gonna vote for
biden
he said but what's happening to you is
not okay
he said and i disagree with it and and
that is just continuing to grow and grow
and grow
to where i think it's it's scary because
i think
we're gonna see more of that that you're
seeing in tunisia
where people are are gonna start hitting
their their capacity
for being pushed around and you can only
say please mr politician let me open my
business please mr politician
let me go back to work please mr
politician i need a stimulus check more
than 600
please mr politician don't send 700
billion dollars overseas we need it here
before people start getting increasingly
frustrated and that's
that that's a pandora's box you know you
know you're going to open something
where change is going to happen one way
or another
um and it it's it's probably not going
to be
a smooth change you know you're going to
see some some bumpy
occurrences during that but i think the
people who are frustrated are in the
right
and i think that they do have a right to
be and i wish that there was a better
way to
to settle it um i wish everybody would
just do what they're doing in italy
you know and and what we did you know we
we opened
we're open no matter what no matter what
you do to us we are going to open unless
we are in jail
we are opening and as soon as we get out
we're going to open again that's been
our plan from day one and if
everybody does that and doesn't get
extreme and doesn't get violent and
doesn't get destructive then we win
and it's it is that simple because there
aren't enough jail sales there aren't
enough sheriffs there aren't enough
handcuffs there aren't enough squad cars
for everybody
and it's a house of cards it's it's an
illusion based on fear
it's fear and control and as soon as
everybody
turns off the tv stops listening to the
politicians and says enough is enough
it's over they can't enforce it yeah do
you know what started the arab spring
no there was a fruit vendor who
was being just harassed by cops told he
couldn't
sell his fruit they would confiscate his
fruit and he just wanted to run his
little
fruit vendor business but they wouldn't
let him so one day he went in front of a
government building and he led himself
on fire
and then the whole country is tunisia
erupted
into mass riding which swept across
north africa into the middle east
and removed some dictators
all because the government because a
couple cops would not let some guy just
run his business
i think it's fair to say what we're
going through right now is sort of a
information war or or a larger consensus
war and once you lose hope
you essentially lose that's why i'm
always personally cheering on the
underdog and maybe that's why i'm i'm
not unbiased it is a biased perspective
where i come from
sometimes but at least i acknowledge it
and i think more of us
should be willing to do that especially
when it comes to kind of calling these
larger
things that are happening right now
because information is key and it could
lead to a lot of
amazing incredible developments but once
you try to
censor once you try to close down this
kind of
wider highway of speech that's really
when we get into
very troubling territories of people
using and abusing it against the weakest
and the smallest in our society and
hurting them tremendously and that's why
when you're doing something that's
helping people get healthy
helping people work out get in a
position where their immune system is
activated
and then you're the one that's being
targeted you're the one that they're
trying to take down it's just ridiculous
and i know and and then i know they took
away your money but there's also i don't
know if you want to get into this or
talk about this there's also other
alternatives with cryptocurrencies
i don't know if you want to personally
talk about that or not and i respect
your decision either way
yeah no that's it it's this whole thing
has been
just a game of kind of staying on our
feet you know it's
when you take on city hall it's a
12-round fight and it's it's it's the
12-round rocky story where you're gonna
get your face bashed in
for 11 rounds straight and all you got
to do is stay on your feet long enough
to get to the end to where
you inspire enough people um and
and you've made enough of a splash and
an impact
that it's a domino effect and you get to
the end because all it takes is that you
know in the rocky store it takes that
that one you know bob and weave and that
one good punch and
and you can take the whole thing down
but it's
it's not falling into the traps that
they're gonna set for you
and they they want that they want the
violence they want the unrest
they want people to go crazy because
then they can say
look at them look look at these crazy
people over here
and that's that that's what happened at
the capitol
you know whether we have all the details
or not that's
that's and they'll use that against you
so it's you have to stay calm and you
have to stay optimistic you know so
that's been that's been my saving grace
all the way through that and i have a
lot i have a lot of people behind me
who reinforce that quite a bit because
it is a frustrating experience when
you're dealing with somebody
who is actively undermining and ruining
your life
the best thing is to just take continue
to take the high road and and
that's been our strategy all the way
through so crypto is just
the next thing for us you know we've
we've done everything we possibly can
and we've we will continue to exhaust
every single resource
without stepping into that trap that
they want
you know so yeah crypto crypto has been
a good option for us and it's going to
be
the way we we move forward in the future
to protect ourselves from from more
oversight i mean excuse me more
overreach
that's an excellent endorsement of why
cryptocurrencies are so powerful
it is but uh that being said it's time
for super chat so if you have not
already
smash that like button subscribe to the
notification bell and go to timcast.com
become a member because we're gonna have
more bonus member segments right now we
have a segment up
with richie mcginnis after he was
defamed by the new york times and cnn
who actually put one of these leftist
insurgents who stormed the capitol
literally the guy runs insurgents usa
they put him on tv like a journalist so
check that segment out it's members only
timcast.com and don't forget go to
timcast.com click that shop button
to get your exclusive i am a gorilla
t-shirt
now we'll read your super chats here we
have i believe this is i don't know if
it's low or io
why haven't you quit sites like twitter
i feel like people are hypocritical
when they talk about hitting big tack in
the pockets but do nothing about it
love y'all well i've talked about
twitter and how i've basically i no
longer use it
in a business capacity i used to post
videos
now i just kind of troll and just post
you know sarcasm and you know i'm
facetious and stuff
but yeah i'm tweeting less and less and
i'm probably going to follow news
organizations and slowly just
not pay attention to it because these
companies are just off the rails man
yeah you just kind of let those things
rot out i think you know
let them run their course and use them
for whatever they're useful for in the
meantime
i think twitter is in trouble i think
they're gonna go because without trump
what's the point of being on there you
know boring
yeah let's see dr rollergator says
two years since vijaya and jack told you
they were going to work on their
suspension policy
they have made no effort to fix it they
want to keep it broken so they have
arbitrary control
free dr rollergater gator did nothing
wrong
adam jeremiah says tim love the show and
i'm a new ish listener thank you for
being a voice of reason in uncertain
times rakhan appreciate it thank you
very much
sporkwich says to be fair 130 37
thousand dollars
is worth about a loaf of bread for which
there will be lines
cough that's a good thing coffin 2021
you know i was wondering actually
there there's some speculation we could
actually hit hyper deflation
because nobody has any money it's it's
so they're printing money like crazy but
it's all sitting in the hands of the
ultra wealthy it's all funneling up to
walmart
so when no one has any money then we get
deflation
and so that what that will do is this is
really scary the people who hold us
debts
will have more power of the us labor
market so countries like china
china looks like china has a dollar and
now you don't and you're desperate
they can get you to do more and more
labor for them for that dollar because
you can't get anywhere else so that's
actually you know pretty scary
all right let's see zab says ian smith
here's the story of rhodesia what
do you understand that reference no i i
have a general understanding of rhodesia
but i don't know where
he was the governor of rhodesia ian
smith oh yeah
yeah yeah i think so because when you
google ian smith there's a governor of
some place that pops up and
it's not you so
kiwi says look up nick kumalatsos
did i say kuma kumalatso as i pronounce
it
he went through a similar situation in
his state and he's got a big youtube
following he now has a pretty awesome
liberty minded youtube channel cool
oh what does this one say tony rogers
says i bet my super chat won't get read
by the way america is turning into the
book slash movie the giver
well it got red uh brenton says ian how
do you feel about rotating deca primo in
eq in the offseason
which ian that's uh out of my wheelhouse
i just i listen to experts when it comes
to that i don't have opinions on those
things
gabe tetter says tim i love will of the
people i rock it all the time
also did you know that stefan molyneux
likes your work
i like you even more now i did not know
that i've briefly met the guy one
time he got nuked from youtube and just
just the purge
is is real and eventually they'll ban
everybody he's awesome man
since way back in the day yeah we used
to make videos like 2008 on youtube
great philosopher took a lot of his
stuff out of context and you know being
a philosopher
you can draw the ire of authorities when
you question almost everything
that's what they did to socrates they
ended up poisoning the guy or making i
drink poison
i don't i actually have not really seen
much of stefan's
videos question everything i saw i saw
one he did on ahmed aubry but that was
about it
i know the media defames them but i
don't take the media at their word when
they accuse someone of being whatever
because they say the same thing about me
or whatever
but uh in terms of will of the people
for those who don't know i have a music
video
check it out it's called will of the
people it's actually one of the top
videos on this channel surprisingly so
thank you all so much for listening to
it
the music video is a short film so you
should definitely check it out it's good
fun
all right let's see we got here kyle
canuck says millennials saying just
print money are doing to gen z what the
boomers did to them
and eventually the house of cards
collapses isn't that right
ale broads says tim you should talk to
lawai 86 and serpents up two westerners
who speak
chinese and have lived traveled through
mainland china they highlight the good
things about china while also calling
the ccp on their atrocities
i watched their channel they're pretty
good i think they're the motorcycle guys
right
yeah i don't know they're really good i
like them love them justin
bookman says once again new jersey
confirms why people hate it
adam wait wait ian good to see you again
you absolute alpha
luke can you recommend any good pistols
i've been thinking about a revolver tim
i just got my harmf shirt can't wait to
wear it when i get home in two weeks
hello liz
awesome yes he did adam is a true alpha
by the way
i'm more of an omega an omega i'm the
omega man
for the previous comment there's a
reason they call it dirty jersey that's
just from a new york city perspective
and second
i love a glock 19x that depends on also
your hand size and what you're doing
with it that's my personal
preference uh a lot of people like
1911's
uh what's that what's the bread i just
got do you remember which one was
uh i forgot the exact one you got a lot
of stuff
so uh i don't know exactly which one
you're referencing for there's a lot of
them we went uh
we went target shooting and i got a
smith wesson victory the fun little 22
but it just jams too much
and we tried different ammo and it's
just the nature of 22 i guess
is is frustrating but it's fun it's fun
when it works you know
but uh uh what was i going to say
something uh whatever all right there we
go let's see
malia ilyan says gym man i need to buff
up how to stay motivated
get your ass to the gym now motivation
um motivation is fleeting it's
dedication that you're looking for and
dedication starts with one day at a time
and that that might sound whimsical and
and nice and fluffy and and but that's
that's it
you win one day at a time and that means
just get up go to the gym
did you find that on pinterest
discipline
you know what's going to say about new
jersey we were running this business out
of new jersey
new jersey had a great opportunity for a
budding new media organization
and boy did they do everything to just
drive
new industry out of the state new jersey
thrives on on destroying itself
they vote for it's the california model
yup yup
let's see what is this jay of legend
says sorry tim you were wrong 18 us code
241
conspiracy against rights two plus
people infringing on someone's rights is
punishable after 10 years
felony it really needs to start being
applied
about assembly speech and guns yeah i
was just thinking that that's civil
rights these people that are getting
banned and
having their civil their freedom of
speech taken away i know they're private
companies but
it seems like a violation of the problem
the problem with a lot of that title us
code
is that the and we've had a lot of
people approach us with that where it's
constitutional law you bring that in
front of the courts and they don't
listen
so it's there's a there's a wealth of
information
about it but nobody knows how to execute
it
you know and and you walk this stuff
into the courtroom and they and they
they'll they'll dismiss it like it's
nothing why is that
i think the the answer would be the the
courts are just corrupt to the court
honestly because there's civil courts
and it's in the constitution stuff's
federal so they don't deal with it
it's administrative law versus
constitutional law and what we
essentially what
from at least from my understanding is
that we operate on administrative law
um and if you go in there citing these
constitutional codes which are valid
um the courts just pretend like they
don't hear you
but i mean this is this is stuff that's
solid i mean it's and it's it's there
for a reason to protect us against stuff
like this but it doesn't really
seem to execute very well michael lopez
says these guys
need a legal defense go fund me that the
government can't touch maybe tim and
friends can set it up and accept the
money and use it to pay the lawyer
this is psychotic they need to win the
case well you guys have
collected donations and you've found a
more secure way to collect
yeah we're just going to go we're going
to go two routes um
the money that we that we get into our
bank account we'll we'll take out in
cash
and we'll keep a nice neat ledger for
all of that and we'll be writing
uh cashier's checks for all of our for
all of our bills we'll just do it the
old-fashioned way and then
people who want to contribute via via
crypto and if we want to save some money
and put it away
we'll put it in into a crypto wallet
into the market
and we'll we'll take it out when we need
it there you go alan law says
squat two times body weight and a bunch
of life's problems go away
the mindset gained along the way
improves every aspect of life
gyms make better people who will go on
to make a better world also high bar
squats are for commies
is that true the first part is true
um no he's got a point it's you know
physical fitness and getting in the gym
and doing challenging
physical tasks translates to mental
toughness yeah um
so absolutely one hundred percent i
recommend
that's another thing any challenging
task like that where where you're where
you're forced to focus you're forced to
work very hard day in and day out it it
teaches you a lot and you walk away
with a lot mentally from that um which
is funny because
coincidentally those are all the things
that were not allowed during covid
things that make you stronger yeah like
sun and vitamin d but that's another
story yeah
and usually it's unhealthy people that
are usually the mean people just saying
zanzibar says your chat is full of
statist crybabies they whine
you don't take a stand but are here
dismissing the boog boys that went out
and did something
lol this is why our republic is lost
well we can we can rag i suppose to an
extent on the boogaloo boys but uh
it's true they went out and they
protested they they did it peacefully
and they expressed themselves and they
gave
the one guy read his statement that left
and right agree
the extraction of you know the wealth
the working class and all stuff they're
not wrong they're you know they're not
wrong
so it's that i think it's pointless to
i think it's funny that they called the
proud boys you know boot looking status
cucks or whatever
but i think the ra what we talked about
we hit on this several times is
all all people basically the
overwhelming majority we agree
the politicians are crooks ripping us
off
so what do we do so long as we keep
arguing like trump is the answer no
bernie's the answer well then you're the
bad guy and we're going to fight now
that's well then we'll be we're not
chasing our tail forever yeah
yeah yeah the the rich people well the
powerful at least i shouldn't say the
rich people because there's a lot of
rich people who are totally oblivious
but the powerful elites the ultra
wealthy
i don't even like calling them elite
because i feel like they're doing their
job poorly
yeah that's true you know using using
lethal force to guard your
your wealth because you're not smart
enough to make it yourself
let's see scott hale says remember the
scene in braveheart when england hires
some scots to fight scots
then they charge each other then shake
hands and give hugs
then they all attack england soldiers i
feel like england is the government now
interesting
lanius shrike says the binding
administration will
will be pure munchausen syndrome his
choice of words has already demonstrated
that he has no real desire to heal as a
nation
he wants the gashes in america's
political sphere to become
gangrenously of infected gangrenously
infected
yeah bryce levine says if everyone
started referring to nancy pelosi as
nancy trump do you think her life goals
would be complete
i don't know should we call her nancy
trump start a hashtag for that one
darth ribbett says biden is going to
reorganize the republic into the first
galactic empire on the 20th
the first global because i don't think
we've actually had a global empire ever
we've had empires but not the entirety
of the planet right
i don't know atlantis seems to have been
one i could be wrong about that but they
bought ancient greece so i'm not sure
that's a real place oh it's definitely
real the eye of mauritania
i read about that but i've also read why
it's not true would you read that
said it wasn't true i was i watched a
video on it that's that that's that that
spherical shape in the sarah right it's
crazy yeah but i read a bunch of you
know breakdowns saying it's just
people are just trying to make it google
map eye of mauritania
and uh we got to talk more about that
kind of stuff too yeah it looked like it
was like
what i've read is that it was created by
like a volcanic underground eruption
that caused a ripple in the earth and
then people settled on it
and that the water had kind of and then
they it looks like you can see like a
straight line it looks like they cut and
carved their way into the ocean the
water because the water was much higher
back then
and created a channel to flood the ring
and then created like an island
paradise pretty interesting looking yeah
nothing like it on earth
kitty like says please ask the gym owner
how many coved cases they have tracked
spoiler alert zero compliance and
passivity are dragging this nightmare
out
live free yeah i see tucker carlson i'm
asking you that question all the time
he loves every time he loves asking that
question he gets it in every single time
how many cases have you had so far
with his squint well i think people who
are healthy and exercising and getting
sunlight
are less likely to to get sick or at
least notice yeah and it's not that
there's no cases i mean people are
contracting it we have
we have people who are nurses you know
they get it they
they get tested they stay away from the
gym there's no
outbreaks linked to the facility that's
the important part is that people are
going to get it they're going to get it
somewhere
in some way or another but if you can
reduce the
the spread that's that's when you're
doing your part
chef brian of telford says i stand for
beer bullets bourbon and god
not necessarily in that order but this
powder but this powder keg's close
yeah man gareth green says ian smith was
the prime minister of rhodesia during
its unrecognized
independence it was kinda white
supremacist but mild next to south
africa
blake green says just bought an
adolescent gym sweatshirt and hat love
you guys
spin the gorilla vitality yeah
i don't have anything to spin but i'll
do it with my hands so what is your
gym's called atlas jim attilis yes
cool what does that tell us i mean i
think it's a spin off of attila the hun
huh oh we inherited the name the huns
get a bad rep man
i think they were actually not the
horrible people the romans made them out
to be
well history is always written by the
winners so yeah oh here's good news
dell men says hey tim want to end on a
positive note flint michigan has had
clean water for almost a year
reported by politico on december 23rd
2020. cool
i saw that that's great news a little
overdue but still good news
father vitality says the only song that
should be in the inauguration playlist
should be will of the people
that is correct and true it was 100 i
think i think at some point i think it's
at like 700 000 views so you should
definitely check it out and put in all
your playlists i don't know what's going
on we
were trying to get it on spotify and
stuff or whatever i'm not uh
staking my entire career on writing a
song i just wanted to make the video
tell the story
have fun let's see
the phoenix of liberty says tim love the
show but come to different conclusions
will the people rocks if it uh it gets
regular play daily on my live 365
station anarchy radio
luke where is your new objectivist girl
objectivist girl huh i don't know i
don't don't know what that means you
named your dog atlas
yeah that might be what they're
referring to was it because you're a fan
of like
the the greek mythology is it was that
less greek is that greek
atlas was the king of atlantis he was
the king of the world the first
same guy yeah he was the first king of
mauritania which is
where the eye of mauritania is and then
they named atlantis apparently after the
guy
really so there's also atlas shrugged
and then you know the
the geographical atlas yeah so all named
after that one guy the king of the
mortality
name cheap which is coincidentally my
dog's name too
that's cool whoa royal wolf says i must
correct a previous assertion high bar is
the superior squat of gorillas
yes correct that's correct fact check
true
bump that guy up in the chat yeah let's
see here we have a i see a two of two
but where's the one of two i hate that
yeah
oh there we go it's right there uh
cutoriously wise says tim and luke i
don't think multi-racial whiteness is
talking about white in terms of race
i think woke use white to mean
individualism classical liberalism
sargon mentioned the existence of
political white and black with capital
w and b and the more i think about it
the more i think
i think woke are trying to move
political white from the extremists to
classical liberals
right well why would you take a
political
ideology or behavior or or concept and
then associate it with all of one race
of people
that's like ridiculous really racist
let's see uh where did we just go
joe spinella says you don't cite
constitutional law you cite under
articles of the bill of rights
you're a man suing another man you lose
all the time under statute civil law
you fight as a man under common law of
court of record
interesting see all this stuff it's
very very hard to you know it i would
love if somebody wants to shoot me an
email and and break it down in in like
meat head terms then i will be happy to
execute you'll get a lot of people
responding to you but not a lot of
meathead terms
gareth green says alpha ian are you
single no i'm not
royal uh all right that one already
kevin collins says need to watch eric
weinstein on glenn beck's show from two
days ago erica is absolutely correct
recommend to everyone
he tends to be he's a smart fella
let's see josh branson says i developed
dedication by simply going to the gym
even if i sat there for an hour i was
there then start working out
not every step needs a leap that's right
it's very very true
it's this it's discipline it's you you
have to uh listen you know
are you are you uh strong you simply
need to choose to be
that's really it and i would what kind
of diet do you recommend to people that
before they go to the gym and after and
things like that
it's highly individual every everybody's
different what works for me
won't work for you i can chicken for
breakfast i can eat a cheeseburger
mid-workout and be totally fine other
people that would send them to the
bathroom
puking you know i would eat sugar and go
and get
devastatingly fatigued yeah because you
hate every minute
you overload you overload your blood
sugar and you crash very hard
you know mid workout um but as far as
what the individual there was saying it
is it's people
especially newcomers have this idea that
everything needs to be accomplished from
day one
yeah and you can you can draw that
parallel even outside the gym anything
anything constructive you want to do
you know it's it's baby steps it's one
thing show up you like to show up just
show up
i like playing hearthstone and so i just
whenever i play hearthstone
whenever on the tremble i just play
hearthstone you know hearthstone is
hearthstone
hearth it's uh uh it's like a i i guess
it's technically a card game
but it's a digital strategy game okay so
you
basically i'll be walking for an hour
before i even realize it because i'm
playing a game you know what i mean you
just occupy your time on the treadmill
but the way what i was saying before is
you know being strong and simply
choosing to be it's
get up and go to the gym and start
exercising and if you're worried about
motivation
you have to say to yourself do you look
do you want to be strong or not are you
choosing to do it or not it's it's
really comes down to you
and i think you need to be conscious of
that you wake up and say i will do this
like i so so i've reduced the amount
i've been producing because
for like three years i was doing six
segments per day which was three and a
half hours
then when we started this i was doing a
ridiculous
amount of like four or four and a half
hours and all that content was me
saying i have to wake up i have to do it
no matter what
there's no question no sense or buts and
now i'm you know trying to re-prioritize
expand and do that so it's you know
restructuring but it really is just
you wake up and don't give yourself an
excuse there's no excuse you have no
choice you have to do it
go to the gym go work out pretty simple
and timlin says unprecedented number of
graffiti in the capital consisting of
veiny units and wagner loves the male
chicken
rachel says you missed my super chat
where do i send physical donations to
you now address is no longer on the
website
because we need to set up a new po box
because we're not
new jersey anymore and we've got to do a
bunch of paperwork and it's going to be
you know kind of ugh so i'll i'll get
that up on the site asap
we just have to go out and actually get
a new po box so
we're getting it sorted uh if you have
the address the old po box you can still
use it
because we we still will be checking the
mail up there too i just don't have the
top of my head so
tyler says for anyone looking to
purchase a gun go to honest outlaw for
all your gun related questions
number one best gun tuber with his 1 000
round reviews
very interesting i made the mistake of
buying nine millimeter makarov
and not realizing it was a soviet bullet
that doesn't work in a standard
nine-millimeter luger and now i just
have a bunch of boxes of soviet bullets
that's cool yeah but i figure they're
like it would be fun to have a soviet
you know gun for target shooting or
whatever so you know
there's like one polish firearm that
shoots it that
we're looking for
yeah we'll find it someone will someone
will super chat or if you have any ideas
send me an email for some
recommendations it was an accident but i
still think it's fun
yeah you know hey i'll take it ammo is
dude i went on i remember which website
i was on but i think i think
cheaper than dirt i'm not sure has like
nine millimeter for like two dollars a
bullet
whoa yeah it all depends on you know are
they hollow points i mean no it's just
been yeah standard yeah like full market
rounds
it's just been crazy what's been going
there's nothing it's all gone
it's all gone it's it's yeah and now
it's man biden
trying to make sure that anything gun
related you can't get online anymore
yup man i think that's a bear that you
don't want to
prod but he's gonna prod it anyway yes
this is the orders apparent like i was i
was hearing from from
due to the gun shop that all the ammo
companies are back ordered and paid for
a year and a half
worth of ammo yeah they're they're
producing
just to ship out like they're not even
they're not producing to sell at this
point they're they're literally
well just backordered yeah a lot of the
big companies are producing for the us
government
there's four major companies all of them
are making it so the u.s government has
their bullets and they're ordering
a crap ton of them wow that's another
aspect here that we need to understand
crazy man gareth green says atlas was a
titan sentenced to hold up the sky on
his shoulders after zeus and the
olympians came to power
those jerks yeah the titans were uh
the children of uh damn i don't remember
the titans they had to fight the titans
we have a mr balls first named stankly
says tim you once said something about
living in a van down by the river
let me tell you something you ain't
chris farley so quit that talk
you should have joey diaz on when you
get an entertainment-centered channel
i mean you know look we we earlier in
the year
we did segments on navajo skin walkers
you know what that is
they're just like creepy little mon like
creepy demon monster kind of things you
know whatever
so we were talking about ufos and we
were talking about strange phenomenon
and just and news and culture
we did a review on movies and then kova
destroyed everything
movies were gone politics became culture
and then
everything we talked about was just like
having everything yeah
we got to talk more about the vamana the
ancient flying ships
apparently people would like kings would
fly around on these giant
palaces like hot air balloon palaces
very cool
i heard that there was like a story in
the bible about rocket ships
or it was taken out of that with the
book of enoch i think will get you most
of the way there
so with a little propulsion orbit is
hard so says elon musk
let's go let's go there that was on my
bucket list when when ashton asked me
where i wanted to go i said
orbit orbit that's that's good ashrae
says i recently dropped 85 pounds by
running and lifting
the fact that gyms are closed and it's
too cold to run outside is killing me
yeah man yeah you know uh that first of
all
85 pounds is a lot of weight to lose so
kudos to you
but if you if you can lose 85 pounds
then nothing should be able to stop you
so that's that's encouraging so
um as annoying as it is don't don't let
that sacrifice or don't let that
destroy the the the distance you've come
so far
you know there's actually a really
simple solution for everybody who's you
know
they've got nowhere to work out just you
know build a skate park in your in your
in your basement yeah just go get a farm
or take a road trip to atillus there you
go yeah
i was kidding by the skate park we have
a very big production facility with a
lot of space
but there you go take a road trip and
hang out at telus and hang out with ian
we are open
and then by the time they got all the
way there
well then they have to commit you know
what i mean you don't you don't do a
trip like that and then
two birds one stone i like that they
could run there why don't they just
run yeah yeah that's your warm-up yeah
how about you know somebody start
walking film it document it
start walking that would be awesome yeah
that'd be great the road to attilis yep
love it let's see mr brownstone says
luke tell teespring to restock 2xl
in l s you were telling me a lot of
people are buying your 2xl stuff too i
guess
for for me as well i haven't checked uh
a lot of this is done
independently through another company
that we're both using but two separate
two separate businesses
uh tim's is i think tim casts right well
just go to temps.com click store yeah
mine is we are changing or slash
shirts uh but uh you know i'm i'm
getting mixed reviews on them to be
honest with you
you know teespring takes a huge chunk
right oh yeah more than i wonder if we
should look into doing our own or hiring
another company
that's what i'm thinking because
teespring is uh
synced with youtube maybe but maybe for
teamcast.com as a proprietary site we'll
do something different but youtube
unsynced my tee springs and i'm like
well maybe we could do something with
someone else out there and if someone is
in that business feel free to reach out
to me on my contact is on we are
where do you sell your shirts in
we sell ours right on the store and we
do everything ourselves and it is
a giant pain yes it is but we we
definitely didn't set out to be an
apparel company and so it kind of came
at us real fast
it just happened where people were like
hey we want to support you can we buy
some shirts
we didn't even even have a website set
up so we just set up a website and then
we got a thousand orders overnight
whoa and then we were like wait we don't
have a thousand t-shirts and we've been
we've been trying to keep up ever since
wow so don't
don't take my advice you have like a
giant t-shirt press at the uh
no we don't we don't print them but we
buy them in bulk we we ship them to a
local printer
we organized them we packed them up it
is there there have been some companies
that hit me up saying no censorship
they were like hey we'll do a better cut
no censorship so we'll look into that
yeah i like that and then you know
you youtube has teespring integration so
i'll just leave that as it is
oh that's a good idea well some of my
shirts were censored and i'm like
what like and then and over the
ridiculous things like a shirt
specifically saying we don't want
a civil war we want the mainstream media
stopping in
antagonizing the civil war got taken
down i made one of the
in my opinion cleverest most clever
shirts
ever and i did a lot of work on it it's
the leftist revolution fist
with a sunburst behind it and the fist
is holding a bike lock
yes and it says liberals get the bike
lock too that's a reference to berkeley
specifically
where an antifa guy spray-painted
liberals get the bullet too
and a leftist bashed someone over the
bike lock so i was mocking them for
being
pathetic and being violent no likey and
teespring was like nah
you can't you can't sell that little two
heads smashy this is like my fifth
shirt too to be fair to be fair
it was too esoteric like if you didn't
understand what it was mocking
it looked like it was violent you know
what i mean i thought that's awesome
liberals get the bike but it was the
leftist fist you know what i mean
so i wonder if like antifa would
actually unironically like the shirt
wear it they'd be like that's a great
shirt
it's true i want it all my epstein stuff
taken down
all antifa stuff got taken down too
apparently like teespring took down a
bunch of antifa stuff
yeah so what we'll find a better company
look we don't want to make sure it's
like
you know yeah that's a lot of work i did
it before i did what you do
we don't want to make shirts that are
like inflammatory or something
yeah just silly jokes but teespring
crack down yeah
you know so actually getting all the fun
out of it yeah the shirt is still
there on teespring it's just that when
you click it doesn't go anywhere yeah
because they're like nah
youtube got really mad they were like
what is this sounds like it's a joke
i was like you don't hear it i sent him
the picture from berkeley
and i'm like it's the revolution fist
and they were like oh so you're like dog
whistling to like promote violence or
something i was like
no it's the opposite it's mocking the
violence
okay i'll take it down smart they they
but they automatically removed it so
let's see let's do a couple more
jor uh jordan stalling says deny
ratcliffe quote
cia management downplayed analysts
report of china influence in 2020
washington examiner january 7 21
that's right yep this is this is strange
nathan klein says can we get luke
mr malice to write a cookbook do you
cook
how's your cooking i think he's making a
reference to a political ideology
and another book that we can't talk
about here
when i get the rare occasion i don't do
it often but when i do get the very rare
occasion i do
like to cook and uh michael come on down
let's uh
let's go cook some stuff i can microwave
we're trying to get this big property
where we can film
fun stuff and make videos and do science
experiments and lasers
and then we could have really fun
experiment videos but man it's really
hard to do right
these days everything's shut down people
don't return phone calls let me ask you
something
has this whole experience made you uh
more on the anarchist spectrum like
moving down closer towards like
libertarian
end cap yeah i mean you're
you're coming face-to-face with a
bureaucratic monster and
the bigger it gets the less effective
and the less for the people the
institution gets so it's it's hard not
to look at it and say
maybe we should do a little bit less of
this this big government thing
so absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
watching all this has definitely made me
like
but i'm i'm i'm like my whole life i've
been pretty
when i was a lot younger i was very far
left anarchist and now i'm like moving
closer to the center and moving up a
little bit towards liberal because i'm
like we got to have some kind of system
but not in these blue states there has
to be but it's the one we have is
is an absolute joke at this point i'm
i'm i'm talking to people out and you
know
out where we're at right in the middle
of nowhere and they're just like all
these liberal transplants coming in and
i was like i'm one of them and they give
me this look
and i'm like don't worry i'm not gonna
vote and they were like okay
no no vote for our guys and i was like
actually i mean
we'll you know we'll see i i might just
keep leave me out of it i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna move to an area that's
better than my past one like the
previous area and then
vote for the messenger yeah but i didn't
i didn't vote for the people in these
these areas anyway to be to be honest
all right let's see here's the lat we'll
do this we'll do one more
chandylan says temple of the feathered
serpent at
tio tahikwan in is a vimana
mercury was found in a chamber beneath
center of the pyramid
the mana is powered by mercury okay
i only understood like a really small
part
quakon was the aztec capital and they're
saying that the temple
it was a vimana like it could lift off
and fly around and document
the temple i've never heard of mercury
being used as a power source but
i don't know much about mercury to be
honest i don't know quick silver they
used to call it
yeah well if you haven't already smash
that like button because it really
really does help
subscribe hit the notification bell and
if you really like the show share it
because word of mouth is the only way we
actually grow this show
if you tell people to watch it and then
they do then they tell their friends
boom bigger than cnn overnight
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member because we will have more and
more exclusive members only
content as the the days progress a lot
of it might be like hanging out vlog
content behind the scenes stuff
and some of it will be special segments
like you know we had richie here the
other day but he wasn't on the show
so i was like come over and let's record
something real quick and we'll throw it
up for members
and it also just keeps us alive on this
show like functioning in the event
censorship will eventually come for us
if we ever end up getting censored we'll
start putting up the videos on our own
proprietary website and crossing our
fingers that we
can sustain the business if that were
the case but if you really do want to
support the show that's one way you can
do it
and uh uh ian do you want to mention
your social media or anything
um a lot of people ask how they can help
and the first way
that i always say is non-financial just
like you were saying share the story
it is has it has been our most powerful
weapon
against what is happening to us is the
exposure we knew when we stood up that
we were gonna
get punched in the face uh and we were
okay with that so long as we could show
the world
what these people were doing and what
extent they would go to
in order to preserve their power so
it doesn't matter who you are share the
story and most of my updates are on
instagram
and that's ian smith fitness but that is
my handle across everything twitter gab
the whole nine yards i'm gonna check out
that uh pocket net as well you ever use
mine
no you should check out mines i
co-founded it it's awesome i'll have to
i'll have to take a peek but ian smith
fitness is where you can follow the
story
um and and sharing the videos i try to
update anytime there's anything major
going on
um and then right in my bio there
there's a link to everything the
attila's website
that's the attila's gym and that's
spelled a t
i l i s dot com there is another
attila's gym
they're not very fond of us so don't go
buy their t-shirts
[Laughter]
so um but that's got all the information
if you want to support us grab a t-shirt
if you want to donate you can do that
and uh and we just appreciate it we
really do cut off we're eight eight
months into this fight and somehow we're
still alive
uh you made a great point sharing is
very very important i mean
it's one of the few ways that people see
my content on youtube.com forward slash
we are change we're demonetized we're
not in the partner
program and seriously that one little
click i tell my people
just scroll randomly whoever dm'd you
and just send this video without comment
whether it's this video or my video uh
you guys are a big part of this i
appreciate it if you want to support me
financially and my news organization
you can on we are change dot org forward
slash
donate if you like the shirt i'm wearing
and want to check out more of them you
can on
we are change dot org forward slash
shirts but more than anything it's
imperative you need to
sign up on the email list on we are
change.org because that's the only way
to really talk to you one-on-one
without anyone standing in the way so we
are change.org is the website thank you
guys again
so much i am a gorilla love yourself
and the shirt's available at timcast.com
and click shop
hey i'm ian crossland you can follow me
on the internet in crossland um ian
thanks for coming man this is really fun
to meet you actually thank you guys
seriously um did no one super chat about
the
covet in the ice cream we did i read
them oh you did i was in the bathroom
oh okay um i think i read like one or
two it's on the new york post so check
out
covid ice cream new york post i think is
news guarded
crazy story crazy story i want to go
deeper on on this because maybe uh if
it's in the food supply we don't wear
masks as much
wouldn't that be novel yeah be great
that'd be cool just limit ice cream
sundaes and we'll be good
yeah yeah go vegan maybe for for six
months out of the year i don't know
there you go all right thanks tim thanks
everybody
all right and then i'm over here in the
corner pushing buttons i am on twitter
at sour patch lids
l-y-d-s and i'm also now on gab at real
sour patch lids because there is an
imposter
she got my name before i did i'm very no
i'm just kidding it's okay she's allowed
to keep it but i am real sour patchlets
on gab follow me there
and you can follow me on twitter
instagram and mines
and also don't forget to check out
pocketnet dot app because they sponsored
us that we're really grateful to that
and it sounds interesting so
i'll be checking that out but uh follow
me at tim cast and check out my other
youtube channels youtube.comcast
and youtube.comtimcastnews we'll be back
tomorrow at 8 p.m live with another
exciting guest
and we'll see you all then thanks for
hanging out
you